chico
[Musique]
h
je
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
ch
moche
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et salut salut à tous à lui a tout
regardé jeu mais là je m'installe je me
cale comment est ce que vous allez
aujourd'hui je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver pour en live un peu
exceptionnel un peu beaucoup
exceptionnel on n'a pas tous les jours
cent mille abonnés byers était pas
aujourd'hui s'il ya quelques jours me
suis très heureux de pouvoir passer ce
petit moment avec vous alors attendez on
se cale on s'installe est ce que tout se
passe bien est ce que vous me voyez bien
est-ce que
la qualité est bonne pour vous est ce
que vous vous recevez oui non quoi
comment dites moi tout ça dites le moi
dites le moi dites le moi je me connecte
je me regarde je vous regarde je vous
écoute alors attendez je vais essayer de
monter un peu le son dans les oreilles
salut à tous vous êtes déjà nombreux
très nombreux très nombreux je suis
habitué à faire des light mais plus sur
twitter et surtout sur twitter on n'est
pas sur twitter sur youtube j'en fais
pas des masses mais je suis très heureux
de pouvoir être là avec vous j'ai
l'impression que mon micro qui déconne
vous avez espèces de
vers une espèce de clips en fait pas un
moment dites moi si ça va bien chez vous
si ça si ça déconne sinon je vais
modifier le le son du micro alors je
regarde un petit peu vous êtes nombreux
lincou coup j'étais en train de regarder
la vidéo de squeeze fait passer à la
concurrence à squeeze salut à tous le
monde s'attaque à monsieur de salut à
vous êtes nombreux saluer go premier
vous êtes nombreux nombreuses j'ai pas
l'habitude d'avoir autant de monde je
suis très heureux parce que forcément
surtout une seconde et un peu plus
confidentielle mais là il ya du monde sa
i-miev très heureux de vous voir
également il ya déjà me naked eye ase
joignent à steve gaming il ya santec
salut à toi santé qui est un habitué qui
est toujours là surtout il salua cédric
qui est présent également comment est ce
que vous allez tous est-ce que vous avez
un problème avec le micro ça fait des
espèces de clopes est ce que vous l'avez
vous chez vous pas parce que j'entends
ça c'est très étrange sais pas si ça
vient de mon casque dites le moi n'ont
pas refait le micro hugo nous dit ok
bon bah écoute et tant mieux si ça
fonctionne un petit clic oui ok on l'a
le petit clic alors je sais pas de quoi
ça peut venir souvent les problèmes de
cliquer ça va dépendre de câbles mais
pour autant attendait sinon je vais
juste s'il ya des effets dessus je vais
les supprimer et on va virer les
traitements ça se trouve c'est ça qui
fait un peu le bazar j'enlève les
traitements on va regarder si ça déconne
toujours autant a priori ça va mieux
donc je pense que le traitement enlever
ça va plus me bouffe et de sons et ça va
aller vous me dites ainsi jamais vous
avez un truc qui déconne alors je dis un
peu vos messages ah ça y est sarr clip
ah attendez je vais changer de souvent
j'aime être sur une autre encore des
mois 30 secondes j'arrive bougeait pas
sur la piste d'un côté on va voir si ça
marche là alors attendez parce que ça se
trouve il ya un truc qui déconne voilà
on se remet et là
normalement ça devrait aller on va
essayer de faire c'est à dire ce qu'on
veut comme avoir du bon son non je ne
sais pas du tout du tout du tout ce qui
se passe est ce que ma robe castor pro
qui n'a pas beaucoup servi fait la
tronche déjà ça serait dommage quand
meme je vous lis tout de suite ça serait
dommage bon on va essayer de passer au
delà de tout ça si vous voyez des truc
qui déconne s'ils sont pose problème
vous me le marquer bien évidemment dans
le chatt moi je vais passer beaucoup de
temps à lire le chat à discuter avec
vous à répondre à vos messages je vous
le dis aussi on va passer un petit
moment ensemble je sais pas combien de
temps je sais pas où la soirée va nous
mener je sais pas jusqu'où on va aller
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que pour fêter
ses cinq cent mille abonnés et bien on
va s'offrir des petits cadeaux ben ouais
on va faire des petits cadeaux parce
qu'on est on est à france à plaisir il
ya au pot qui m'a dit tiens monsieur
crois que tu as prévu de faire un truc
particulier concours pour novell et
compagnie du bas-rhin non c'est vrai que
j'aurais pu le faire mais ça demande
beaucoup d'organisation et comme je suis
toujours ne juge pas je n'ai pas acheté
pas gérer mais je leur ai dit par contre
il ya un live qui arrive parce que
normalement il ya quelques temps je vous
cache pas qu'on ait eu cette discussion
normalement le palier des 500 milles
abonnés devraient se passer au mois de
décembre et ce qui est arrivé donc on a
deux smartphones à vous offrir avec au
pot le réno si c'est le réno syspro donc
rester bien ensemble restait bien
connecté ça va être réservé uniquement
aux abonnés de la chaîne tout comme le
chat a d'ailleurs si vous regardez cette
vidéo tout de suite en direct sur
youtube et que vous voulez pouvoir
réagir participer il suffit de vous
abonner à ma chaîne c'est gratos sûr
vous abonner si vous n'avez pas fait
vous pouvez actionner la petite cloche
comme ça vous serez identifié dès qu une
prochaine vidéo à vous connaissez un peu
l'histoire et puis je vous recommande
très important de vous prendre un petit
verre alors moi j'ai ma petite
grenadines monsieur grübel et grenadines
petit grenadine pour moi je vous incite
à prendre un petit verre sans alcool la
fête est plus folle comme ça on trinque
et on passe un bon moment ensemble
l'injure
c'est formidable
alors je dis un peu vos messages bien
évidemment le sortait que 10 500 milles
ces dingos c'est dingue aux 500 milles
pour moi c'est un truc qui complètement
dingue parce que quand j'ai commencé ma
chaîne youtube je me suis inscrit en
2015 sur youtube est très très
honnêtement je me suis inscrit pour bien
moche paul je m'appelle je vais
m'inscrire j'avais un blog à l'époque et
j'ai commencé à faire mes vidéos fin
2016 et
west l'histoire de ma région et faire
des vidéos mais savait pas trop quoi
comment j'adorais la tête j'en parlais
un tout petit peu et puis je me suis
rendu compte que derrière ben en fait il
y avait vachement de réaction donc j'ai
aussi deux cas ça pourrait peut-être
intéressés plein de gens donc j'en ai
parlé de plus en plus puis ça danse ça
depuis je suis gamin et puis je me
rappelle fin 2016 début 2010 elle je me
suis dit allez je vais 10000 abonnés je
crois et je me suis dit c'est trop cool
ce qui se passe je vais essayer d'y
aller à fond et je me faire une vidéo
par jour tous les jours tacos j'ai pris
mes billets pour aller au cms à las
vegas début 2017 et puis ensuite
l'histoire a commencé là dix douze mille
abonnés début 2010 cette journée
anniversaire le 28 novembre 2017 je
passe la barre des cent mille abonnés
août 2010 8 200 mille abonnés strauss
kahn
2020 n'ont entendu dès 2019 trois cent
mille abonnés enfin bref ça monte et la
voyons se retrouvent afin fin 2021 vous
êtes 500 1000 et je suis trop heureux
merci à vous merci merci énormément
vraiment sérieusement du fond du coeur
parce que vous êtes là vous réagissez
voilà c'est trop cool je suis très
heureux donc merci à vous merci à vous
tous merci à vous tous d'être présent je
voyais mon pote jo elle qui est passée
bravo encore à jann marc simon petit
bonbon petit jojo on a on a eu
l'occasion de craquer il n'y a pas
longtemps donc je suis très heureux
merci d'être présent sur le tchat un
merci aux copains d'être présent je
regardais un petit peu vos messages ça
fait trop plaisir question comment te
sens tu après avoir atteint 1 500 mille
abonnés vas-tu te contenter de ça ou
toujours plus moi je regarde du coin de
l'oeil lui millions je vous cache pas
que ça va être compliqué je fais
beaucoup de travail pour y arriver mais
j'adorerais donc on va rester humble on
va beaucoup travailler puis on va
essayer de se réinventer pour poser de
nouveaux formats pour ce titre vous
faire plaisir également et puis il ya
tellement plein de belles choses à faire
donc on va pas rester serein on dit
comment se reposer sur ses lauriers on
ne va pas se reposer sur ses lauriers
croyez-moi
salue monsieur bré la forme et je vais
très bien j c merci pour tes
encouragements
bien le bonsoir de vichy ravi tant voir
en live merci à toi dit si c'est pas
très loin de chez moi donc une prochaine
file plaisir on passera fait un petit
coucou vichy continue comme ça tu
provoques du bon contenu merci tu me
restait trop gentil merci lucas s'était
mérité nous dit jean charles c'est très
sympa merci jean charles merci pascal
allias mon pote arnaud qu'elle a
également arnaud ca les ventes
nationales est super bien il parle
arnaud de d'ordinateurs
déconfite de gaming des trucs super bien
petit passage rapide félicitations vont
tous les points cinq cent mille merci
mon chéri c'est tellement beau et
surtout mérité attendait ça va tellement
vite j'essaie d'en monter sur les
messages sur sept les meilleurs pour la
suite god millions merci beaucoup d'un
amour j'adore ce que tu fais merci
beaucoup êtes des messages adorables
salua en route corse 2b qui est
également présent souvent sur twitch je
veux revenir sur twitter je ferai des
live en fait la juge au jeu repose on
redescend je pense que vous le savez il
ya le réveillon de noël dans deux jours
je pense que vous le savez normalement
c'est au courant et je vais essayer de
briquer un petit peu passer un peu de
temps famille préparait bien évidemment
la rentrée de janvier avec un départ si
tout se passe bien je touche du bois
pour aller au csa las vegas si c'est
possible cl je peux le faire et j'essaie
je laisse un peu ça si c'est possible si
j'y arrive avec elle à la pandémie
actuelle donc ça serait ça serait
vraiment génial j'ai l'impression que je
suis un peu sur exposé au niveau de la
lumière donc j'ai vu c'est un peu la
lumière où j'ai pas on essaie de se
faire un truc propres voilà ça devrait
aller un petit peu mieux comme ça on va
regarder le résultat je le trouve très
pâle ou sur le retour c'est pour ça ou
ça craque de tous les côtés rien ne va
plus voilà on fait attention
on attend tous le chiot midouze oui moi
aussi c'est le premier smartphone qui
sera annoncé avec le stade dragon huit
jeunes one donc on attend ça aussi avec
impatience aura grâce à en tout cas bien
jouer road to lemieux luis enrique merci
beaucoup cédric tekken sous tu as vu mes
messages pour invitation au nouveau
format alors j'ai vu passer excuse moi
j'ai vu passer un message sur
instagram je crois je suis sous l'eau je
regarde je te réponds très très vite
super chan au pire de suivre merci
giovanni le million millions de ça on
espère me un grand bravo et merci pour
tes conseils aud'imat numérique merci à
toi est très joli pseudo
sympa dernière vidéo exil collectionner
piété garcia ouais c'était trop cool on
était à hawaï à quoi un mois non non il
va ya attendez c'était fin novembre l'a
non il ya moins d'un mois ont été à
hawaï c'est c'était tellement tellement
dingue c'était vraiment vraiment
vraiment génial
bonjour comment est prêt pour mettre
tous ces sujets avec les je me renseigne
j'aime je teste c'est vraiment en fait
pour moi ma chaîne sais c'est pas on
n'est pas sur une chaîne médias on est
mon idée c'est que moi je suis passionné
de teck et je vous emmène avec moi je
vous emmène découvrir et puis on regarde
ce qui se passe on partage ensemble
c'est vraiment le truc qui me fait
kiffer c'est le partage de pouvoir lire
vos commentaires alors je suis désolé
une fois de plus je tiens mon excusé
platement et je sais je sais c'est
vraiment ma faute j'ai pas toujours le
temps de regarder tous nouveaux tous vos
commentaires de d'y répondre surtout
j'ai toujours un oeil donc vous avez des
pas je regarde si jamais bien loin mais
je suis toujours un peu sous l'eau je me
suis un peu moins sous l'eau en début
d'année donc je sais pas me rater un peu
plus présent tu as bien régler ton
shooter l'image est pas fluide alors
j'ai normalement a mûri fais gaffe à ça
je suis sûr
obs live et si tu as un conseil à me
donner t-il avec grand plaisir
j'essaierai d'améliorer ça tu peux me
laisser dans le chat bien évidemment
ça fait cliché mais perso depuis que tu
connais ta chaîne j'ai pas acheté un
truc texan avait tété 0 merci beaucoup
hésitent à remplacer mon minutes 10
temps qui va en teck ton mais notre
disque hard le parce que je pousse
vraiment pas à la conso donc il faut
garder les projets et les smart
répandant il en est le plus loin
possible génial et vidéo lady juliet
merci beaucoup julien merci à josy à
bravo pour les 500 mille cas grenadine
oui on est toujours à la grainerie j'ai
soif et je vais parler tellement que je
bois
il ya un smartphone qui ce qui se fait
entendre pas très très loin
tu dégage une bonne humeur ça c'est trop
gentil merci beaucoup
bonsoir monsieur greuze je te suis
depuis 2007 je tenais à te féliciter
pour tout ton évolution ça c'est clair
depuis 2006 s'est passé des choses
babet qui est présente bravo champagne
bisous abad est à
meyrannes viens de te suivre ça c'est
sûr tandis que celle qui vient d'arriver
sur twitch assistante which d'accord
qu'on a un petit message de tout ce qui
arrive en même temps ici tout se mélange
à celle du multiplateforme allez savoir
pourquoi pas tu va commander quoi comme
téléphone pour noël mieux ce groupe g
pas commandé de téléphone sache qu'en ce
moment je tourne sur l'iphone 13 promax
je trouve très cool
c'est devant un peu vos messages ya
tellement de choses tellement tellement
tellement tellement je t'aime nous dit
bilek bas merci moi aussi je t'aime j'ai
l'honneur 52 très content il est très
cool les honneurs 50 quand commence le
concours pour gagner les smartphones est
en calmons nous on a un peu de temps je
sais pas et je vous dis tout de suite
sur totale impro je ne sais pas comment
on va le faire mais on va le faire on va
se faire un petit concours dans le tchat
on va trouver un moyen je pense mais ça
va être rigolo monsieur gros le boss
dans ses toiles eux bossent en auvergne
aussi pour les fêtes et tu sais où à ok
était calme sous tu viendras les matins
bien raison en ce moment il ya un espèce
de brume au dessus de chez moi on voit
rien mais c'est très sympa quand même
merci mais c'est plein de messages super
cool
sarr anaïs cayla bonsoir salut à toi
très heureuse très rare de voir des
messages féminin c'est très très très
masculin mon audience et quand je vois
passer
un pseudo féminin ça me ça me fait ça me
fait plaisir
iphone 13 promax mais tu encourages pas
mon surnom j'encourage pas sûr qu'on
accole à la consommation si vous voulez
un beau smartphone et que vous avez les
moyens l'iphone 13 promax marche très
bien mais quand le vôtre sera arrivé au
bout de sa vie parce qu'il faut pas
aller trop loin
jaguar 814 dont j'ai tiré bâtir et bat
viens de te suivre l'enlever le retour
de twitch je pense que c'est des
personnes qui sont tout de suite dans le
live sur youtube et sébastien il est sur
twitter on va aller on va les sabots
n'est donc on pourquoi pas on fait du
cross platform tu habites en auvergne
toi aussi tu es dans quelle ville je
suis à clermont ferrand a mûri voilà
pour tout te dire tu sauras tu où
j'habite à clermont ferrand depuis
longtemps
cool de vivre de ta passion ouais c'est
vrai ça c'est un truc qui ouvre parce
que je me suis jamais dit qu'en fait en
lançant sur sur youtube j'allais pouvoir
en vivre un jour c'était pas du tout le
but c'est que je vais trop de bruit dans
ce micro ça me paraît toujours démentiel
de se dire ça aujourd'hui mais
ok je suis heureux que ça se passe comme
ça parce que ça me permet de découvrir
plein de produits ça me permet de
voyager ça me permet voyez d'être là ce
soir pouvoir échanger et ça c'est
vraiment trop trop cool donc trop trop
trop heureux j'aime rick j'ai cassé mon
téléphone j'aimerais savoir quel serait
le meilleur choix entre six heures et
demie en fashion in n'ote 10 pro et le
samsung à 71
écoute je t'enverrai bien sur l'a71 tout
de suite
ou alors tu vas sur le
web à 60 ans c'est pas mal du tout c'est
pas mal du tout
monsieur gros j'ai une question je doute
pour weight 50 par rapport à ce que tu
sais tu pense qu'il sera présenté les
prochaines white and see wait and see j
ai absolument aucune information
là-dessus aucune aucune question à force
de tester les pliant
force de tester pliant clients de
téléphone comment rester sur un seul
téléphone à oxygène ont pris ce qu'ils
m'ont afin de tester plein de téléphone
comment rester sur un seul téléphone en
fait moi je mon téléphone que j'utilise
tout le temps à titre perso c'est
l'iphone 13 promax pas ce qui me
convient très bien au niveau de la vidéo
et c'est un des usages pour moi les plus
importants tout de suite tous les autres
téléphones comtesse dans les hauts de
gamme sont très bons en photos et en
vidéos liens avec son site excellent
mais savait que j'utilise déjà parce
qu'il est très bon vidéo en plus de ça
j'ai une coque monsieur gros donc ça me
fait trop plaisir mais a fait pas
réellement pour la coke c'est c'est
surtout parce que comme je fais mon
montage sur un macbook que j'utilise
final cut pro et que je ne connais pas
première et bien il ya une une vraie
connexion au niveau l'écosystème et que
ces pratiques voilà pour tout vous dire
mais si vous voulez d'excellents
photophone les video phone vous allez
chez one place non plus tôt chez samsung
veut dire où elles sont très bons en
photo ou en vidéo gérés plus chez
samsung vous trouverez toutes superbes
pour éviter que l'image ne soit pas
fluide avec comme guest live le mieux
c'est d'activer le beat frey dynamique
dans les paramètres avancés à tanger
c'est un petit coup d'oeil dans les
paramètres avancés le beat frey
dynamique qui me disent ah ok why not
alors attends ça doit être ça doit être
dans avancé
[Musique]
je cherche reconnexion automatique
alors attends vidéos format tac tac tac
tac tac tac enregistrement on s'en fiche
activé retard de stream activé
utilisation la mémoire tampon est ce que
c'est ça je sais pas retard de stream
peut-être durée de 20 secondes
ah ouais un retard de stream tu crois
que c'est ça qu'il faut faire peut-être
ajusté dînette d'el hajri ajusté
dynamiquement le débit du streaming en
cas de congestion de réseaux bêta je
sais pas si c'est ça qu'il faut faire ou
pas
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas voilà ce
que j'ai donc dis moi ce que t'en penses
parce que c'est tout ce que je peux
avoir sinon on attend à ce que j'aime
notre truc là
je suis sûre obs live 1 donc il ya
peut-être des trucs que je ne connais
pas le bi très dynamique je regardais je
trouve pas dans ce que j'ai cités ce qui
est un truc qui te parle dis moi j'en
garde en même temps les messages
dsit pas me le dire
si je t'écris sur twitter tu réponds
j'ai beaucoup de messages sur les
différents réseaux et c'est vrai que
c'est pas particulièrement simple pour
moi question tu as acheté ou ton et ont
gelé acheté dans une boutique à main
j'ai mangé le nom je l'avais mis l'autre
jour sur
mon nez ont gelé acheter comment
s'appelle cette boutique où j'ai acheté
le néon c'est une boutique corinne c'est
des mecs qui sont à paris et on nous
avait recommandé je suis pas déçu si je
retrouve le nom je te le dirais tu es
flou je suis flou là ça me paraît
bizarre je sois faut dire que moi parce
que light le boîtier généralement je
suis pas floues c'est bien ça a juste et
le beat frey le bitrate machin machin
était bon je regardais
paramètres paramètres avancés
[Musique]
gst dynamiquement j'ai médecin mais je
peux pas le modifier carte réseau
adresse ip source du fluide on ne peut
pas le faire interface par défaut je
peux pas faire actionner cette gauche-là
cette case là je ne peux pas
[Musique]
je veux mettre le retard de stream on
verra ce que vous me direz ce que vous
en pensez si ça va mieux comme ça j'ai
fait une petite modif vous le dirai
après un coup
félicitations bravo voisin un coucou
d'histoire salut aux issoiriens pas très
loin de chez moi
bientôt un super test où on avoue duo ou
un avis sur le au pot find n alors le
hollow fine c'est le nouveau smartphone
pliable de au pot on verra peut-être que
je le verrai l'année prochaine si je le
vois bien évidemment je vous en parlais
sur youtube en priorité mais ça ça a
l'air intéressant et connaissant le
travail de au pot je ne doute pas que le
produit soit de bonne qualité avoir à
voir comment ils ont intégré ce qu'ils
ont fait aussi d'un point de vue
logiciel parce qu'ils ont un truc qui
est vachement intéressant par le
logiciel donc on regardera ça
attendez vos messages
monsieur petit pouce bleus merci
beaucoup pour nos amis les chinois qiao
me gênerait demi note 5 et il marche
encore nickel depuis maintenant quatre
belles années merci pour tes conseils
continus merci à toi et merci pour ton
message
il est bien le au pot find x3 n'est au
niveau de la photo il est pas mal du
tout et il est pas mal du tout le nez au
niveau de la photo tu peux y aller
est-ce que la pliure ou la rainure sur
les tells plions sus vite ou non
je les ai passées sur deux ans donc tu
vois ça c'est compliqué de te dire
j'en ai pas un usage quotidien j'en
connais qui l'ont usage quotidien et
pour l'instant tout va bien donc pour
l'instant ça fonctionne que pensent les
tablettes de wayne ou démolis pour les
tablettes de huawei moi ça c'est pas mal
hein c'est pas mal et tablettes de
huawei mais une fois de plus tout en
sachant qu' on est sûr sur la galerie on
n'a pas les services google on a les
services de huawei donc à voir si toutes
les applications et téoz âge
correspondent à sa main en terme de
hardware purement matérielles ibos très
très très bien chez huawei alors ces
tests bmw électrique est ce que tend à
penser au final en
matière de teck embarqué moi je trouve
ça vachement bien ils sont sur la
huitième 8e génération tech embarqué
alors partis sauf toi je trouve vraiment
pas mal et j'ai bien aimé je me suis
bien marré à faire ça je peux un peu
frustré parce que j'aurais pensé que
j'aurais espéré que ces vidéos
fonctionne un petit peu mieux et on ya
combien taux de succès m'a regardé et je
vais vous dire sur ces vidéos
on est
tum tum 7000 vu j'ai publié deux jours
la bmw i 4ème 50 c'est pas terrible du
tout du tout du tout et la x1 xdrive 52
bm on est à 15 mille cd super véhicule
alors c'est vrai que l'on peut dire est
qu'un peu de redire sur la partie
logicielle parce que c'est là mais le
même software en fait que vous avez
entre laïques sellal 4 way ce ne sont
pas les mêmes véhicules ces mêmes
software mais je me dis tiens à ce que
ce que ça plaît pas l'automobile en fait
est ce que est ce que les gens viennent
pas sur ma chaîne pour voir l'automobile
est ce que du coup bon ici où je passe
mon tour je regarderai pas ce que c'est
c'est pas mon truc dicle moi ce que vous
en pensez parce que bon c'est un peu
c'est un peu un peu un peu frustrant
parce que moi j'ai j'adorais faire ces
vidéos on s'est vraiment éclaté on a
passé un week-end de fou et on a bossé
comme des dingues pour sortir une vidéo
chaque jour hélas avec eux c'est enfin
on est deux jours de tournage le samedi
et le dimanche le samedi c'était la x le
dimanche c'était vraiment la i 4 et je
suis un peu frustré mais bon après
peut-être qu'il faut du temps aussi pour
que ça ça évolue des petits coeurs pour
que du côté des vidéos merci à philippe
a pourtant laissé en 1965 et mieux que
kirin 980
[Musique]
moi je pense quand on arrive ensuite
considérations là on est vraiment sûr du
sûr sûr sûr les petits points de détails
je pense que ce qui est important en
fait si tu sors kirin secteur huawei ça
veut dire que tu es sur la bière y que
tu n'es pas sur les gms et sur les hms
donc la question ne se pose plus tôt là
dessus au lieu de penser en termes de
perte pure emmené son smartphone
jusqu'au jusqu'au top du top du top et
qu'on le mette au plafond de ce qui peut
faire au maximum pense plutôt d'abord en
terme d'expérience logiciels du
catalogue d'applications
à mon avis je le prendrais comme ça
si un étudiant basse leur réalisation et
montage qui te suit depuis un bon moment
bois tu envoies un cv pour un stage de
cinq semaines en février mars a des
chances d'aboutir
bah ça dépend ce que tu veux faire parce
que sur le montage j'ai déjà quelqu'un
qui bosse dessus mais écoute a mûri
enfin - email talent et coordonnées qui
sont dans sur mon
savon à propos sur ma chaîne youtube tu
m'envoies un mail et tu me dis ce que tu
voudrais faire et puis on en parle je
sais pas honnêtement et puis dis moi où
tu es explique moi tout ça on regarde sa
part mais en tout cas pourquoi pas il
faut il faut comprendre bonsoir monsieur
réflexion passe à 120 abonnés quels sont
tes attentes pour les nouveaux
smartphones de 2020 en fait moi ce que
j'aimerais bien voir c'est de laisser de
l'innovation parce que c'est vrai qu'on
le voit un on le voit en fait il ya
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
smartphones qui sont ressemble au bout
d'un moment et le truc qui me plaît
toujours c'est l'innovation donc
effectivement ce qu'on a vu ce qu'a
annoncé au pôle avec son find eyes find
n son smartphone pliable ça me plaît
parce que oui tiens une nouvelle copie
d'un smartphone pliable qu'est-ce qu'ils
vont avoir fait quelle manière ce que ça
va marcher ça c'est vachement cool
j'aimerais voir vraiment ce que va nous
faire aussi samsung avec sa nouvelle
gamme s qui sortira alors pour l'instant
il ya que des rumeurs mais bien
évidemment il ya rennes confirmé on n'a
pas de date que dalle forcément on verra
ça l'année prochaine c'est toutes ces
innovations qui m'intéressent des
smartphones dans l'entrée milieu de
gamme qui se ressemblent il y en a des
tonnes maintenant je veux du lourd je
veux de la recharge sans fil sans fil
mais sans contact mais voyez à distance
je veux voir un peu ce qui se passe en
termes d'innovation et voir ce qui
arrive et voir les form factor qui vont
arriver plus tard sur des choses plus
sourire et veulent voir comment est ce
qu'on arrive à intégrer smartphones et
metaverse et peut-être des choses à
faire aussi durant des ponts donc encore
plus loin ça c'est probablement dans les
années encore plus en 2025 2026 et 2027
mais voyez comment c'est entre
apercevoir ça ça serait en tout cas qui
est super intéressant à regarder bien
évidemment tout ça de très près
alors je regarde la voiture et bien oui
mais c'est normal que la vidéo fait si
peu de vue car personne ne t'attends sur
la présentation de véhicules kaléya
youtuber spécialisés pour ça oui je suis
d'accord mais moi en fait ce que
j'explique dans les vidéos tu vas sur
l'automobile c'est que je suis pas là
moi pour vous parler de cylindrée vous
parlez de couple vous parle enfin j'en
parle vite fait comme ça mais moi je
parle de l'ateq embarqué est en fait et
c'est pour ça que les marques vont venir
elles viennent me le font venir les ans
maintient en forme hier des gens de la
tête parce qu'ils vont parler de l'ateq
embarqué n'ont pas l'expérience avec
leur smartphone est
telle qu'on m'attend pas là-dessus tout
de suite et qu'il faut un peu de temps
lorsque fois plus explicite en sais rien
il faut il faut réfléchir parce que moi
je suis convaincu on savait c'est la
tech
le smartphone c'est l'objectif que tout
le monde a avec soin c'est une évidence
mais pour autant la têt kalé partout
aujourd'hui vous voyez sur les monts les
ordinateurs mais dans les voitures aussi
dans les maisons donc pour moi il ya pas
de limites il n'y a pas de frontières
tant qu'on parle de take on parle de
connectivité ne peut pas y avoir de
frontières il faut juste qu après
peut-être que je ressens rien que soit
plus explicite là dessus je sais pas
peut-être améliorer le format en tout
cas c'est sûr que c'est pas un carton
plein est et c'est un peu décevant mais
je me dis qu'il faut que j'améliore faut
que je fasse mes donc c'est bien ça ça
motive de se dire il faut que je
réfléchisse mais on va y arriver la
vôtre
jeudi à la moitié ça promet
[Musique]
tu trouves pas ça dommage que les
grosses marques comme samsung ne tendent
pas grand-chose à l'encontre de xiaomi
alors attends
que les grosses marques comme samsung ne
tombe pas grand-chose ne tente pas
grand-chose à l'encontre à ok tu veux
dire comme si on me ou comme ray bien
moi je pas d'accord avec toi pour moi ça
me sauver ils ont une gamme à qu'ils ont
réécrit complètement il ya trois ans je
crois qu'ils plus clair plus lisible on
comprend mieux les produits et puis dans
l'entrée milieu de gamme y est très joli
produit après c'est vrai que xiaot me
erin mis encore plus aujourd'hui enfin
fut omis - aujourd'hui mais c'était un
peu la outsiders donc on les attendait
pas et ce qu'ils ont fait c'est énorme
donc c'est normal qu'ils aient une
petite très agressive si tu regarde par
exemple chez ont mis leur stratégie
c'est quoi c'est de proposer des
produits à tous les prix ce cas est pas
lié dix auront 10 ont dû trouver un
smartphone de chez de chez au mit donc
c'est ça l'idée donc bon non non pour
moi j'ai donc le marché super tâche et
c'est comme ça
merci merci steve bonne année à toi
également ton avant dernière vidéo tu
faisais de la danse classique sur la
miniature j'étais en train de sauter en
fait oui ça fait un peu dans ce
classique
j'espère que tu m'en voudra pas jeter
intégré dans le générique de mon nouveau
format car tu fais partie des gens que
je veux recevoir t'es gentil merci
beaucoup je regardais ça grand plaisir
en tout cas et on en reparlera n'oublie
pas je te répondrais bien évidemment
c'est vrai qu'il ya un concours ouais ça
arrive ça arrive ça arrive ça arrive
vous inquiétez pas est-ce que je vais
parler domotique un jour j'en parle un
petit peu j'en ai parlé un peu au
travers de google gens par y avait
peut-être un peu mais mais ouais il faut
réfléchir il faut réfléchir à voir de
quelle manière on peut parler domotique
pour ce soit intéressant pour sa part et
la rebaptise why not je me fais un pas
de porte même si tout de suite je sais
pas c'est pas dans les plans je trouve
ça hyper intéressante par l'etec
embarqués dans les voitures mais à mon
avis si ce genre de vidéos font aussi
peu de vue c'est aussi vu du prix de ses
voitures oui je suis d'accord à mourir
mais si on regarde bien l'innovation
commence toujours par le très haut de
gamme et ensuite à l'heureux décent et
et c'est là où ensuite d'autres
constructeurs vont intégrer des choses
intéressante donc des gens comme bmw
sont fait pas dire à l'avant garde des
innovations parce que c'est un peu que
c'est hyper galvaudé dire ça mais ils
ont un truc est vachement bien fait très
bien pensé et
et c'est cool d'en parler tu vois ma
demain il ya renault qui m'appellent et
qui me dit viens monsieur heureux sur la
zone et on a un truc de dingue en termes
de connectivité géré avec grand plaisir
j'ai pas eu de message mais en tout cas
ça m'intéresserait mais ok peut-être
peut-être peut-être peut-être au verbe
je suis un gars nommé ça
j'ai un au pot à 5 2020 c'est pour
savoir ce que tu en penses je ne pas
tester le haut point 5 de 2020 donc ça
que je saurai pas je serai pas quoi te
dire tout de suite quels sont tes
prochains tests de téléphone qui vont
arriver sur la chaîne on se parle de
huawei
après demain je crois je crois celui-là
lenovo 9
le nova 9 est intéressant de nos vingt
neuf et c'est toujours intéressant de
parler de huawei parce que vous savez
c'est un peu ils sont faits un peu cassé
les patins avec l'histoire des
des services google qui dont ils n'ont
plus accès mais ils ont rebondi d'une
telle manière avec une stratégie avec
une évolution au niveau d'harmonie os au
niveau de la galerie c'est vachement
intéressant ce qui se passe donc c'est
pour ça je suis content de pouvoir
parler de huawei l'écosystème et monte
en puissance s'ils continuent sur leur
lancée et s'il arrive à ramener de plus
en plus de développeurs dans quelques
années vous allez voir une alternative
de fous furieux avec du hardware de très
bonne qualité avec un écosystème de fou
une inter compatibilité entre tous les
matins souhaite communiquer aussi bien
un moniteur un pc un smartphone une
montre et ça va évoluer donc s'il y
arrive je pense que dans quelques années
on va avoir du gros gros gros lourd bon
pour l'instant il est encore un peu tard
mais ça évolue c'est intéressant comment
vois-tu mercedes-benz son côté
technologique je n'ai pas testé à mine
c'est mon pote jb qui a vu la dernière
mercedes qui lui du coup pour étendre
par les bavards sur sa chaîne parce que
moi je les gg pas de contact avec avec
mercedes donc peut être une prochaine
fois le s20 f5 j'étais toute actualité
le s20 haeffelé déjà sorti il y passe un
régime de feu je sais plus si non je
sais plus
à suivre à suivre bien évidemment ton
producteur préféré de l'année 2021
ça c'est une question compliquée il ya
quad
je sais pas si j'ai un truc où je me
suis vraiment dit ouah je crois que le
truc qui m'a le plus surpris cette année
c'était le au po x 2021 sa valeur leur
smartphone enroulable parce que c'était
différent ça ça m'avait bien plu alors
ce n'est pas un produit fini mais ça
j'avais aimé donc ouais c'est tout qui
m'a le plus hype et je crois
que pour souder shiomi on se tait pro je
me rends compte que je n'ai jamais parlé
je voulais présenter très rapidement
mais j'ai pas fait de vidéos de test
dessus très très bon smartphone le
chimiste est pro il est cool je vais
voir si je peux rattraper mon retard
mais je suis tellement tellement et on
est fin décembre je sais pas si
aujourd'hui un intérêt à faire une vidéo
sur youtube mais on se tait pro on va se
concentrer peut-être plus sur le chiot
midouze qui sera chez nous dans deux
mois je pense avec un peu de chance on
verra on n'est pas là
j'ai deux
chimios tes propos find x3 néo un niveau
de la photo à m je dirais le phénix
trois néo t'as pas trop aimé le pixel
six pros j'ai beaucoup aimé le pixel six
projets trouvé très intéressant mais
j'ai trouvé trop loin il va trop loin au
niveau de la photo dans ce que j'ai vu
après j'ai vu d'autres potes qui l'ont
utilisé voyez on était on était à hawaï
avec anne fans et guyane et ben pape a
pas de souci a salué un super rendu je
trouvais que c'est enfin de ce que j'ai
vu quand je vais tester je crois que ça
allait un peu trop loin après c'est que
du software mais mais j'aime bien ce que
fait google ça vachement bien ils font
des trucs super intéressant et j'aime
bien j'aime bien ce qu'ils font en
termes de software mais je pense qu'il
faut que tout le monde se calme cela en
fait avec le lia au niveau des softwares
vous faites des photos à contre jour ben
ils
vouvoient et le contre jour n'existe
plus
vous décidez de faire une photo de nuit
la nuit bientôt elle existera plus il
fera jour maintenant vous mettrez en
ciel bleu quand il fera nuit on va trop
loin il faut garder les pieds sur terre
par rapport à la photo une photo c'est
une photo voilà on veut faire la photo
qu'on embellie ce qu'on améliore des
choses suis d'accord mais il faut pas
qu'on fait des choses qu'il faut plus
naturel et là je suis allé trop loin je
me suis mis sur un bon contre jour et on
voyait ma tronche presque en noir et
blanc parce que le traitement logiciel
contraste tellement avec le reste ça
marchait pas quoi pour moi c'est ça
marchait plus ça va ça allait trop loin
mais sinon j'aime bien
qu'elle est là pour toi qu'est attend
quel est pour toi la meilleure vidéo
2021 quand tu me parles de vidéos tu me
parles de quoi de ma vidéo à moi parce
que je serais incapable de te réponds si
c'est le cas si tu me parles d'autres
vidéos je prend pied de te répondre je
sais pas comment vois-tu les futurs de
one piece avec au pot aujourd'hui je
vois pas autrement mais c'est dommage
ils mutualisent des choses ils ont un
marketing différents
mais ouais je sais pas on va voir
comment il arrive à avancer c'est
compliqué ya tellement d'acteurs
instruments du rhône a c'est pareil vous
avez vivo qui va mettre le paquet vivo
il va ils vont y arriver avec plein de
belles innovations ils nous ont montré
n'y a pas longtemps que vous avez fait
un petit un petit youtube shirts à ce
sujet sur des innovations qu'attendent
empreintes digitales vachement oran vous
posez votre voix une fois dessus pas
filer scanner vous savez quand vous en
train de paramétrer vos smartphones ils
vont en espagne de ce thème qui est
super intéressant vous prenez votre
smartphone en vidéo vous lancez une
vidéo donc la vidéo allez hop là c'est
normal et vous tournez votre smartphone
plus tourner comme ça et la vidéo elle
reste droite c'est un peu comme sur
l'ego procédé le maintien de l'horizon
c'est ouf c'est vraiment bluffant et ça
marche bien c'est vraiment très très
très bon
et tu as ip par le s 21 et feu pour
l'instant ce smartphone n'existe pas
donc jour où il existera on en parlera
salut aurélien des projets pour l'avenir
des tonnes déjà on va commencer par
finir et faire ce qu'on fait le podcast
qui va repartir à partir de la rentrée
justement si tout se passe bien le crs
en janvier twitch qui va continuer bien
évidemment évolué et je vais travailler
à fond pour améliorer tous les formats
sur youtube vous avez déjà fait une
vidéo la rentrée de septembre les ans il
faut que ça change je m'ennuie faut
faire évoluer les choses évoluent et
s'est passé tellement vite c'était
tellement complexe tellement speed et ce
qui me permet de me dégager du temps et
d'avancé sur tous ces trucs là c'est
qu'en fait la g g comment vous dire j'ai
j'ai délégué le montage c'est plus moi
qui fait le montage alors je dis ce que
je veux comment il faut que ça se fasse
mais je le fais plus et ça me soulage
mais vous imaginez pas comment ça fait
gagner trois à quatre heures de boulot
par jour où je vais pouvoir justement
bosser sur plein d'autres choses faire
évoluer d'autres réseaux tic toc
notamment qu'un réseau je trouve pas
choquant intéressant instagram essayer
d'améliorer présent si sûr sur facebook
donc à plein de choses à faire mais
voilà donc là je me dis que je je
redescends pour la fin de l'année la
semaine prochaine quand je sentirai
absolument rien et puis on recommencera
en fait à la semaine d'après depuis
vegas avec les nouveautés j'irai tout
voir aussi baisse pour vous donc ça va
être cool
est-ce que tu va tester la gamme selon
mireille min 11 oui dès que ce sera
possible alpha avec grand plaisir
moi j'ai un raid remy set mais je pense
pas c'est sûr au pot après on peut aussi
une très bonne marque donc là dessus dit
aucun problème
god game pour les 500 cas tu m'a
beaucoup aidé quand j'ai acheté un mrc
monsieur gros si je peux rendre service
ua pour ça le z flip 3 est il bon et
j'aime beaucoup le z flip 3 c'est un
super smartphone il y perd canon
smartphone préféré j'en aime beaucoup
celui que j'utilise au quotidien jeu
pour te dire c'est l'iphone 13 promax
qu' une petite tuerie très équilibré
très cher mais très très beau smartphone
[Musique]
entre nous quel objet cadeaux de marque
lors de tests et cetera tu n'utilises
pas est une trouve plus d'utilité
maintenant je teste beaucoup de
smartphones donc les utilise pas tous
les jours tous ses biens et bien
évidemment j'ai beaucoup de casque qui
dorment dans les placards que j'aime je
garde pour pouvoir écouter plus tard
tester comparer des proches des trucs
tech j'utilise beaucoup tout ce qui est
philippe siourd la maison il ya des
lumières bleues la cdu philip sion et
donc il y en a partout chez moi tout ce
qui est google nest utilisa au taquet
tous les jours
les eaux qui google les utilise dans
tout le temps j'ai tout le temps là
dessus qu'est ce que j'utilise pas il y
en a où j'utilise pas la maison je vous
ai parlé pas longtemps c'est le gaucho
10 d'amazon que je trouve très bien mais
je lui ai pas trouvé sa place donc il
faut je trouve sa place mais j'aimerais
bien le maître dès que je pourrai salue
monsieur heureux que penses tu du au
nord 20 pro
est ce qu'il est conseillé de passer à
money alors je sais pas du tout harmonie
os sur le au nord 20 pro je ne sais pas
du tout je n'ai pas du tout d'infos sur
le calendrier déploiement d'harmonie os
donc je saurai pas très bon je suis
désolé je suis vraiment pas répondre et
les crottes de nez ça ce moment je les
crottes de nez ça ne se mange pas voilà
c'est pas bon pour la santé un
attends attends attends olala ça va
tellement il était bon mais ça je me
suis dit je suis pas un huitième temps
message comment vont tes enfants j'en ai
un seul sait si j'en ai d'autres je suis
pas au courant et ça serait dommage les
crypto je ne parle pas de crypto je me
sens pas compétent aujourd'hui mais
c'est un sujet qui m'intéresse je
regarderai à titre personnel et si j'ai
des choses à vous dire est que je me
sens légitime et compétents n'ont pas là
on verra ça peut-être plus tard est-ce
que
mercy syrie c'est avec grand plaisir de
par2 pas parler avec toi est ce que tu
as déjà été contacté par un boulanger
pour présenter un produit tech j'ai déjà
fait des partenariats avec boulanger
ouais j'ai déjà fait et le dernier
c'était une télé de soliste de cette
année
tes objectifs pour 2022 faire évoluer la
chaîne faire évoluer la chaîne au taquet
trouver le nouveau format se réinventer
je crois que c'est ça en fait je crois
que c'est ça le truc et puis faire
évoluer tous les autres réseaux aussi
parce qu'il ya plein de choses à faire
tweet je trouve ça vraiment trop trop
cool ce qu'on fait tout de suite on
pourrait le faire sur twitter ce côté
live j'adore donc tweet ça me plaît je
sais pas si je ferai d'autres lives sur
youtube s'est passé un truc qui vous
plaît et que tu leur dis que moi tout de
suite est ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
date live de temps en temps dit comment
one you and me white tu préfères quoi
one way puisque fabbrini veille tu
rentres moins sûr clairement du coup tu
as raison ça caille et là je suis à
clermont il fait froid hier on a été
faire une balade il faisait je crois -
jack lang - 2 on est monté en haut du
dupuis du paréage s'appellera aux
auvergnats c'est un puits qui est juste
à côté du puy de dome d'ombré dans les
volcans on est vraiment en altitude eh
ben il faisait 5 degrés donc autant vous
dire que sur clermont il ya une espèce
de brume là qui garde tout le froid et
on se cailler les miches
comme on dit chez nous et quand une
nouvelle vidéo de bmw peut-être l'année
prochaine je ne sais pas du tout on
verra
[Musique]
salue monsieur gros creux
hbv de strasbourg tu te rappelles alors
strasbourg ci est ce qu'on s'est vus
quand je suis venu pour l'émission
amazon dis-le moi un 10e mois dit de moi
street photo alors c'est peut-être être
qu'on s'est croisé qu'on a échangé dis
moi si c'est ça si je me trompe pas je
vois un coin de votre
wii pour les lie way clairement va
surtout si tu veux des live tels qu'on
fallait faire plus tout est choyé
vas tu allais au cs de las vegas est
prévue j'ai mes billets tout est réservé
tout est calé maintenant il faut juste
voir si les us s'en remet pas et si
c'est si c'est possible je suis vacciné
troisième dose je suis fou l'attaqué je
peux y aller voilà mais il faut faire
attention je pense très très au sérieux
toutes les problématiques de sanitaires
donc on va voir on va voir on va voir
salut du québec salue à pierre tu serais
pas de famille de céline 3,3 un
salut aurélien pour le gaming tu me
conseilles quoi sur le blackjack car
black shark 4 ou le readme j'étais poggi
plus précisément ça me parlait ça change
j'ai pas testé le black jack black shark
4g appelée à parler donc je te dirai
remy j'étais parce que j'ai pas testé
l'autre quel est ton point de vue sur
android 12
ça mériterait d'être
plus développés comme réponse mais c'est
bien j'aime bien travailler douze noms
c'est intéressant ce qu'ils font ils
l'évolution gens trouvent toujours
intéressante après c'est à tout un
chacun voir s'ils s'y retrouve si ça
vous plaît ou pas moi j'ai opté du
puy-en-velay à d'affaires froid puis
revenait aussi un pc portable équivalent
macbook pro mais en windows va regarder
chez huawei ils ont de belles machines
chez asus aussi sont super belle machine
attendez de voir peut-être ce qui va
arriver en début d'année prochaine parce
qu'avec le csc d'avoir des annonces très
sympa il faut voir il faut voir mais
pour tester beaucoup de huawei je dirais
qu'ils sont très très belle machine sur
les met debout kicks hyper canon ça
dépend ce qu'on va en faire une fois de
plus ça dépend des diagonales d'écran ça
dépend ce qu'on veut et j'aime bien ce
qu'ils proposent aussi chercher la
russie sont très très très très joli
c'est ce que je dis non exhaustif
absolument je trouve ça dommage que tes
vidéos soient moins honnête mon moi
honnête moins honnêtes est ce que tu
penses que mes vidéos soissons - on est
certains c'est un sujet intéressant tu
peux me le dire il n'ya pas deux il ya
pas de tabou on peut parler de ça moi je
pense pas que mes vidéos soins moins
honnêtes mais je suis up ce sera du midi
non écrit avec grand plaisir pour en
discuter sans aucun problème tout de
suite bien évidemment à caen en voyage à
new york a raté j'ai loupé ce message je
voulais répond tu tic
salut à sétif qui est passée par là
également j'ai besoin à tout le monde
coucou à temps en temps à quand un
voyage à new york ça me rappelle t vidéo
sur ma table je passe à new york je
passe à dire que le 1er janvier en fait
je pars de paris ont fait paris new york
avec une escale de 17h jusque jeu avec
mon pote léo qui vient farl qui vint
cadrer avec moi et ensuite on passe la
nuit à new york qui repart le lendemain
à 15h direction vegas donc on va passer
un petit peu à new york vite fait je
suis parti de chez moi y est arrivé 12°
arrive à montluçon -2° à montluçon s'est
il fait froid
tu penses quoi du galaxy s 20 f 4g bien
à karim la question se pose sur la 4g
est ce que tu veux la 5g dans les années
à venir ou pas du tout c'est ça que la
question est intéressante est ce que tu
peux me recommander un photophone à
moins de 500 euros
pixels 4 à
mais il est un peu vieux mais bon
pourquoi pas va voir la vidéo sur les
smartphones at j'ai fait une vidéo
qu'elle smartphones achetés à moins de
500 euros et dans le tarif 400 à 500
euros va acheter un coût de ce côté là
je sais plus ce que je t'avais dit mais
va vous répondre cette vidéo là
tu trouves que les smartphones
deviennent trop orange ne trouve pas que
les smartphones deviennent rouges pocono
poche devient trop petit je pense qu'en
fait les smartphones et agrandissent
parce qu'il faut augmenter les montées
les surfaces aujourd'hui pour tout ce
qui est sage gaming et visionnage et
c'est logique mais voilà c'est surtout
ça
s'allume monsieur brochet noah
strasbourg il fait très froid aussi tu
te rappelles de moi
hbv oui on s'était pour l'émission
amazon on s'est croisé à la cathédrale
ok je me rappelle très bien je me
rappelle très bien on discute et j'avais
une vanne en face cathédrale moi j'étais
atteinte était juste en face de moi on a
parlé un petit moment oui je me rappelle
c'était c'était il ya un petit moment
déjà c'était cool
[Musique]
que penses tu du rhume il 8i
intéressant c'est pas le smartphone de
l'onu mais intéressant tons nude studio
qui nous en parle alors une housse
studio je vous en parle sans aucun
problème le nouveau studio en fait il va
il va il va il va comment vous dire il
va évoluer il ya un néon je suis content
un gros logo monsieur grande et on sait
pas si vous l'avez vu si vous n'avez pas
vu je voulais montrer tout de suite on
ne bougeait pas bougé pas bougé pamelap
1 1 on va pas se priver pour garder
dédaignons on aime les néons les néons
ces grosses machines mais j'ai tellement
de photos bullshit dans mon truc je sais
même pas pourquoi attendez j'ai essayé
de vous retrouver le néon le néon néon
le néon le néon le néon le néo l'âge et
les trucs de bmw saône ce ne sont pas
des néons je confonds pas voilà le nez
au hockey trop cool le néon le néon le
néant voilà hockey regardez
ça c'est les ondes c'est mon mur chez
moi dans mon nouveau studio à paris et
c'est mon nouveau nom et je suis trop
fan de ce néo parce que ça donne un
effet qui est génial et sur la brique
c'est la vrai bric 1 c'est pas une
brique de décor c'est de la vrai bric
dans l'appart je suis trop fan je vais
faire un nouveau bureau qui donnera sur
le mur qu'on verra derrière avec le logo
en est on je vais mettre plein
d'éclairage ça va être cool et on sera
des lives la bad et live tweet ch ça va
être trop trop cool je suis trop content
il faut un petit peu de temps le bureau
va être installée je pense en tout début
d'année il ya encore un peu de déco à
faire mais je pense que si tout se passe
bien mi février début mars on a le
quasiment terminé et là on va envoyer du
steak les copains c'est trop cool
faut-il rester sur la quête g je ne
pense pas je pense que vrai usage de la
5g on n'y pas encore tout de suite mais
on y arrivera dans les quelques années
qui arrivent mais si on a besoin de bien
plus de débit et de moins de latence la
5g intéressante mais les vrais visages
de la 5g on les attend a livré bénéfice
de la 5g on les attend quand même si
c'était intéressant ce qui se passe
[Musique]
je regarde
je profite des conseils pas d'aller à
new york c'est l'enfer avec locaux vides
je veux juste y passer de 17 heures j'y
reste pas mais j'adore new york c'est
dommage c'est trop cool cette ville
salue monsieur groupe tak tak
est ce que tu penses que les mises à
jour du logiciel ne font pas ralentir
les téléphones ça dépend des fois moi
j'ai une vieille expérience là dessus je
me rappelle c'est sûrement un vieil ipad
et j'ai fait une mise à jour mais envoie
sa mise à jour fait pire après il faut
avoir une machine qui puisse quand même
même si les fans en fait des marques
vont vous dire vous pouvez faire votre
mise à jour sur ces vieilles machines là
mais quand la machine commence à être
trop vieille
et vous risquez d'avoir des surprises il
se peut c'est pas dit c'est pas sûr mais
quand j'ai une machine qui a cinq ans et
que on pousse une mise à jour je suis
pas sûr d'aller dessus en tout cas pour
tout vous dire
[Musique]
passion smartphones ne dit
qu'ils la voûte sur la sur loire
lavoûte-sur-loire ok pour ma part
monsieur groupe auteurs réunis les
auvergnats
attendait
dans un futur proche par leur attitude
lunettes connectés ainsi que des
cassettes augmente en vue du metavers
c'est bien évidemment un sujet qui est
incontournable on n'en a pas encore
parlé mais on en parlera quand il y aura
des peut-être des produits ou des choses
qu'ils commenceront à arriver c'est ce
qui s'annonçait comme le futur
d'internet donc le métavers ça va pas y
couper on regardera on apparaît de plus
en plus dans les temps à venir dont il
note que penses-tu la surface gaudieux
est elle encore d'actualité
ouais une fois de plus ça dépend des
usages
qu'en viens-tu dans le sud ouest c'est
pas prévu pour tout de suite d'orient
c'est de regarder les messages en même
temps et puis on va se faire le bon on
va se faire le jeu bientôt pour gagner
le premier smartphone rasséréner les au
port et no 6 donc restez connectés ça va
être cool je sais pas comment on va le
faire je sais pas du tout mais je vais
s'y trouver un tout une idée un peu à la
con
je crie dans son téléphone dans ce
téléphone allô
c'est un micro ce n'est pas un téléphone
le second c'est un micro est-ce qu'on
peut installer et bien utiliser
photoshop illustrator sur un macbook des
14 ha bah oui bien sûr ça dépend après
ça va dépendre de tes projets si tu veux
ça dépend le nombre de cas là ça dépend
ce que tu veux faire mais tu peux les
installer oculus quest 2 g le quest un
mois j'ai pas le 2 c'est pas intéressant
un bon soir en passant heureux pour toi
merci nono bruno
tu en penses je pense quoi du metaverse
je pense que l'état verse
c'est un support différent c'est une
approche différente du web qui a un côté
un peu fantasmé flippante mais parce que
on a une vision
un peu de ce que nous raconte j'ai pu
lire la littérature mais en tout cas les
films de science fiction et la
littérature d'ailleurs à ce sujet
maintenant
ce qui se fera c'est ce qu'on voudra
bien faire aussi est ce qu'on voudra
bien adopté et il ya un truc il faut
vraiment se dire c'est que on a la
chance nous en europe et encore plus en
france d'avoir de vrais garde-fous donc
il faut voir si je peins moi je me
rappelle quand j'étais gamin je rêvais
je rêvais de mettre un casque sur la
tête et jouer à des jeux comme ça quoi
viens donc l'idée du metaverse c'est un
truc que moi en tout cas je me reproche
déjà 8 ans petit dessus voiliers de la
même manière que je m'imaginais ou
d'aller chez le coiffeur de mettre un
casque paf j'enlève j'ai ma coupe donc
donc cdc des choses que j'imagine en
fait voyez c'est donc pour moi le
métavers ça a un sens c'est un sens mais
une fois de plus et si vous voulez c'est
un peu la désillusion d'internet on
pourra en parler parce que moi j'ai une
vraie grosse désillusion sur internet
j'ai un très gros fan internet jeu quand
j'ai commencé en temps de parler du web
dans les années 90 j'ai dit c'est génial
c'est ouverture parce que enfin on va
pouvoir accès à des choses que j'adore
moi j'étais fan de groupes de musique je
dis je pouvoir avoir plein de sites sur
eux et quand j'ai trouvé le premier site
son héros favori jeu j'ai imprimé tous
les sites imprimés j'imprimais j'avais
des pages est énorme c'était débile mais
j'avais tellement l'impression que
j'allais plus pouvoir le voir et la
promesse internet d'un monde ouvert avec
un accès à l'information génial de tous
les côtés c'était extraordinaire donc
cesser à la fin ce qui est très ouvert
mais quand je vois où on en est
aujourd'hui et ce qu'on a fait alors
c'est génial a envoyé six ehpad en
lettres serait pas en train de vous
parler intentions mais y'a côté un peu
désillusion un peu un peu gueule de bois
quand je vois le nombre de conneries qui
se raconte
les discussions de comptoir sur internet
j'ai l'impression que en fait il ya une
partie internet qui étaient ouvertes
génial où on apprend on s'ouvre au monde
et il ya une partie qui est tellement
tiré vers le bas voilà alors rien n'est
parfait un bien évidemment maintenant
qu'est-ce qui va arriver avec le
metaverse je sais pas c'est compliqué
est ce que ça sera le seul support est
ce qu'on n'aura pas d'autre support des
écrans je sais pas c'est très compliqué
parce que on imagine le métavers sans
réalité virtuelle famille dans un casque
mais on peut très bien imaginer des
choses avec une réalité augmentée est ce
qu'il y aura un côté holographique
quelles vont être les technologies de
demain enfin on n'en sait rien
aujourd'hui on n'a qu'une vision en
entend parler du metavers ce à l'horizon
2025 2026 mais on sait pas ce qui va
arriver dans les années à venir en terme
de techno et comment ça va évoluer donc
on peut pas voir plus loin que ce qu'on
connaît aujourd'hui donc il faut un peu
de temps il faut un peu de temps mais
c'est au son du métal ne trouve vraiment
intéressante donc à voir on verra on va
sur toute la très près
il faut une sèche et s'ils croient pas
ce qu'ils 75°
bonne idée d'installer windows 11 / -
mais si ça dépend regarde à voir si ces
logiciels sont tous compatibles mais si
t'as pas de problème là dessus
tu envisages détester dit fonda sa barbe
pourquoi tu me dises ça faisait pas ce
qu'il faut je me rase non je ne pense
pas
dommage de renault 6 a pas un bon
processeur tu ce sujet de l'offre tu
peux le prendre aussi un non il est pas
mal de renault si ça dépend ce qu'on va
en faire
bonsoir fait 300 mille cas as tu un
produit coup de coeur cette année ce que
disait alors jérémy en fait une
innovation que j'ai beaucoup mais c'est
avec le au pot x 2021 smartphone
enroulable fois c'est intéressant
pourquoi tu montres ton adresse à un
description je ne monte pas mon adresse
est une boîte postale pour m'envoyer sur
veut m'envoyer un petit courrier on peut
le faire mais c'est pas chez moi donc
rassurez vous si vous venez à cette
adresse là où 49 rue de ponthieu vous
arriverez dans une galerie marchande pas
chez moi bob l'eponge maiden et le wind
megadeth manowar les me voilà on les a à
peu près tout cela à peu près tous
thiam te regarde depuis le sénégal
coucou à tous nos copains sénégalais à
toutes les personnes qui sont en afrique
également sur le continent africain nous
embrasse tous si vous êtes très nombreux
c'est très cool je le vois dans les
stats donc c'est très très cool cool
quoi toutes les personnes qui se situe
aussi outre atlantique je pense au
québec aussi qu'ils sont qui sont aux
etats-unis puis en afrique et en
amérique du sud
c'est rigolo de voiliers parce que quand
je regarde les stats jockey des mondes
des gens dans le monde entier et ça
c'est vachement cool en donc je suis
très heureux de pouvoir lire tous ces
messages vous êtes de partout donc c'est
bien alors attends on va regarder le
message de ligne ça qui m'intéresse
pour maman de vivre en fait une pause on
verra ça plus tard je trouve tes vidéos
moins honnêtes car elles sont
pratiquement tout sponsorisé exemple la
vidéo sur le pc portable 2nd g mais le
pc portable 2nd g le lg g il est
vachement intéressant mais toujours que
j'aime bien en fait il ya un truc alors
je comprends ce que tu dis c'est
légitime et j'entends 1 300 % en fait
moi dans ma façon de voir les choses si
tu veux il ya des produits gérés pas
testé naturellement par exemple le lg g
serait jamais allé le tester pas que
c'est pas un produit qui m'aurait pas
intéressé mais que je vais je vais fait
beaucoup de focus sur le smartphone et
quand el jem a dit maintien on aimerait
bien que tu parles du lg g on voudrait
proposer une sponso jara déjà si les
produits jouent très intéressant je
regarde s'agit en tout cas raconté
dessus et puis je vois si j'y crois si
le produit j'y vois un intérêt si si il
me plaît ou pas et s'il me plaît à ce
moment là on y va si maintenant le
produit me plaît pas on n'y va pas et
clairement il ya des gagnants plein que
je refuse je vous dis tout de suite je
dis non non je ne vois pas ce que j'ai
racontée dessus ou produits m'intéresse
pas je vois je me sens pas légitime où
j'ai pas envie mais ce produit et je
trouve intéressant alors je comprends et
c'est ce que tu dis c'est un truc qui
est
normal en disant ok y'a marqué
sponsorisés il est payé par la marque
c'est du bullshit en fait ce qui se
passe dans les process comme ça qui
explique la marque elle m'envoie un
produit par exemple le no 29 de huawei
tu vois c'est une vidéo qui réalise en
partenariat avec quoi il est testé un
partenariat car oui qu'est-ce qui se
passe je discute avec huawei ou lg 1 et
ils me disent bien voilà nous le produit
notre fiche technique bon c'est une
fiche technique c'est des specs c'est
comme ça il ya après on n'atteint pas
comme on veut mais c'est une fiche
technique huawei c'est pareil dit bah
voilà le produit voilà ce qui fait voilà
l'écran qu'on a me voilà la batterie
volaille processeur voilà ce qu'on fait
avec voilà toute l'histoire ok
maintenant fais ce que tu as à faire ok
je fais ce que j'ai à faire je fais mon
contenu je teste le produit je m'amuse
avec le smartphone je prends je vais
faire des photos le pc je vais dessus je
me balade je m'amuse bras je fais ma
petite vie et une soirée thématique vie
je fais ma vidéo je l'attends ici la fac
tac tac c'est mon truc tac à rien
d'autre ni bourreau
pour fait les vidéos mais voilà je fais
ma vie ici et ensuite la vidéo je leur
envoie le non pas pour qu'ils me disent
ah bah non sans veux pas que tu le dises
ils me disent ils veulent vérifier que
tout ce qui est
dit correspond légal c'est à dire que je
dise pas de bêtises en fait et des fois
il arrive qu'il y ait des choses où on
dise
je vous dis un truc là par exemple j'ai
fait une vidéo avec lg en partenariat
sur des des écouteurs où ils disent que
vous avez de l'infrarouge lumière
infrarouge qui tue 99 99% des bactéries
sauf que c'est des bactéries escherichia
coli et un staphylocoque doré donc ils
ont été tellement pointe chose en vous
mettez leur mettez le en tour écrivez le
parce que je pense qu'ils se sont fait
embêter et il met à un moment qu'on vous
l'ouvrez bouyer petite lumière violette
et bien dire cette lumière violette ce
n'est pas l'ultra violet parce que le
travail ne se voit pas c'est pas une
lumière visible par nos yeux donc vous
ne la verrez pas donc il ya ya ya toutes
ces questions légales qui veulent
verrouillé parce qu'ils veulent pas de
procès votre pas être embêté il m'est
déjà arrivé que des marques me disent je
dis ça on n'est pas d'accord alors là
c'est intéressant parce que l'on excuse
avec la marque jeudi en battant des vous
vous n'êtes pas d'accord moi je pense
donc si vous me demandez moi de tester
et vous me demandez de sur un contenu il
faut que le discours soit honnête si
j'ai le discours ne doit pas être
honnête je ne le ferai pas et il est
arrivé dirai pas pour quelle marque que
je publie un truc donc la marque était
pas on a beaucoup discuté alors à la fin
on arrivait à un accord où ils sont ni
ben ok c'est ton point de vue ok ok mais
je le publie alors il m'arrivait des
fois qu'une marque mais est ce que tu
dis au début qui est un peu dure est-ce
que ça te dérange pas de le dire à la
fin je veux bien faire ces aménagements
là mais dans tous les cas je le dirai je
le dirai je ne changerai pas donc voilà
c'est ma façon de bosser avec les
marques et je comprends quand on me dit
tu fais une opé spawn sauter acheté par
une marque alors je suis payé par une
marque c'est une certitude mais pour
autant mon discours les lie les honnêtes
et si toutefois la marque elle me dit de
lire un texte de réciter de dire que
c'est de ne pas dire ce que moi je pense
est bien gérée pas je m'arrêterai on
arrêtera la coloc ça m'est déjà arrivé
avec des marques d'aller loin et de dire
non là on va s'arrêter parce qu'on va
pas y arriver alors la plupart du temps
on a réussi à discuter et je leur dit
non parce que ça c'est important et il
faut le dire je ne peux pas dire un truc
positif si je pars de ce négative et je
dis pas d'une parce que pour moi ça me
pète tout ma crédibilité il en est hors
de question et puis 2 2 sommateurs il le
verra lorsqu'il aura le produit vers ax
pro truc là ça marche pas et que moi je
n'ai pas dis donc non il faut être
honnête et ça c'est obligatoire à 300%
maintenant il ya un truc et je sais que
c'est comme ça que ça marche c'est à
dire que des médias les journalistes ils
sont ils sont payés par la rédaction ou
la rédaction enfin et ensuite ils ont un
côté publicitaire qui fait rentrer de
l'argent mais journalistes qui l'ont pas
un lien direct avec l'argent sur youtube
nous on a un lien direct avec l'argent
ça fait que les agences ne sais pas
comment ils fonctionnent mois travail
tout seul donc bien évidemment je suis
payé par une marque mais pour autant je
ne suis pas là pour chanter ça chanter
ses louanges et ça c'est vachement
important et voilà mais maintenant quand
une victoire que ma vidéo et les mots
honnête sur le pc portable de lg est ce
que tu penses que je vais pas assez loin
dans mon test
je peux l'entendre est-ce qu'il faut que
j'aille chercher des choses que j'allais
pas chercher peut-être aller plus loin
peut-être peut-être mais en tout cas moi
ma démarche allait au met je te l'assuré
à 300%
quand tu as une sponso à tulle droit
à la transparence où on en demande dans
ce sens et non me demande pas d'enfant
c'est ce que je dis en fait un mois pour
moi c'est la transparence et aujourd'hui
si vous voulez et je dis ça en tout en
tout comment dire je me raconte pas une
histoire j'ai la chance d'avoir une
chaîne aujourd'hui qui fonctionne pas
trop mal sur youtube et d'avoir d'avoir
ben vous voyez vous êtes nombreux dont
quelques par les marques elles voient le
nombre et à un moment on discute elles
peuvent pas m'imposer des choses en
disant non tu dis ça tu dis ça et puis
si ça se fait pas c'est pas grave tant
pis je travaillerai avec d'autres
personnes si on n'arrive pas à
s'entendre eh bien on part pas fâchés
mais je préfère qu'on s'arrête là parce
que pour moi le plus important c'est
sais ce que j'ai à vous dire c'est
l'honnêteté du discours c'est la
transparence voilà mais c'est je ne peux
pas vous dire mais c'est hyper
transparent
salue monsieur woerth je suis depuis
l'afrique de l'ouest coucou facebook
près 500 milles car je te remercie en
pensant en passant que penses-tu d'apple
et du pliable auront-ils vraiment la
chance d'en voir dans les années à venir
oui quand le marché sera mûr et quand
apple aura une solution qu'il leur plaît
réellement mais je je je les imagine pas
passer à côté d'une innovation majeure
donc je pense oui quel est ton
smartphone coup de coeur plutôt clients
plutôt normal plutôt un tiroir qu'est ce
que je vous disais tout à l'heure au pot
x2014 j'avais adoré mais une fois de
plus je n'ai pas utilisé sur une période
où je vais pas vous dire
les smartphones que j'utilise
aujourd'hui sont des smartphones qui ne
se plient pas parce que
pratique sur l'iphone 13 promax très
pratique mais ya pas de jolies
smartphone qui se plie et après c'est
une fois de plus ça dépend de ses usages
c'est quoi ton casque là là tout de
suite ces internats kg s'est engagé dans
ces meilleures dynamiques c'est le dt
770 profond 250 home pour tout te dire
bonjour tu n'as pas fait de vidéo sur
les opposants cauffry 2 mai
est-ce que ils sont bien je les ai pas
testé ces tests ou pas je les teste
plusieurs de chez plus que lesquels j'ai
testé dernièrement de les écouteurs de
repos mais il y en a plein que j'ai eu
et les écouteurs j'en fais pas de fait
si je faisais des vidéos sur tous les
écouteurs qu'on ne passe je serai une
chaîne presque que ça ccg on est
beaucoup pour tout te dire le fait les
stations moi j'adore tes vidéos merci
michael je te souhaite une bonne
continuation merci pour ton message
vaut mieux acheter un iphone 5g aux us
ou en europe
je
te dirai en europe je te dire en europe
et la tva
[Musique]
est parti faire une vidéo plantations
que l'euro est douze fois je pense et on
parlera également de manuel 4
quels produits pour noël j'ai fait une
vidéo dessus sur les produits de fin
d'année pire c'est qu'on nous dit est ce
que quand tu un sponsor la marque tu
donnes le produit où ils le récupèrent à
la fin du lg g j'ai des marquis messe
des produits huawei par exemple ils
naissent les produits lg je sais pas je
sais pas s'ils vont le récupère et
peut-être c'est possible la plupart des
produits que je reçois il repart tous il
y en a que je garde
et qui reste dans les placards soit des
utilisent à la maison
les moniteurs par exemple que m'avait
laissé huawei je vais utiliser mon
nouveau set up j'utilise du pc également
mais oui il y en a quelques-uns qu'on
blesse ça se voit que tu une personne
honnête remercie molly
j'essaye au maximum de faire attention
et vous savez j'ai conscience d'un truc
c'est que quand on fait quand on est soi
même sa propre marque et que moi je veux
tout gérer maison il ya juste le montage
que j'ai délégué parce que je n'en
pouvais plus et que ça m'empêchait
d'avancer sur d'autres projets mais
c'est important de se dire attention il
faut mettre des garde-fous faut faire
gaffe pourquoi je suis là pourquoi est
ce qu'on vient s'abonner à mashhad
pourquoi est-ce qu'on m'écoute et si on
perd cette vue et si on fait n'importe
quoi et ben et ben et ben on déconstruit
tout ce qu'on a fait donc il faut
vraiment faire attention et et puis moi
une fois de plus ce qui m'anime c'est la
passion celle qui faisait un petit fin
je vous cache pas que c'est un kiff ce
que je fais depuis bas depuis que je tu
commençais ma chaîne youtube or il
fallait un peu de temps au début je me
cherchais j'adorerais faire ça et puis
le fait de pouvoir être passé à à 100%
dessus c'est un kiff je m'éclate pouvoir
je n'y a pas d'autre mot c'est un kiff
absolut pouvoir partager ça avec vous de
voyager voyons et eia il ya un mois à
wye avec jb pp avec anne et puis tous
mes potes d'autres pays que j'ai je
rencontre lors de voyages c1 qu'il n'y a
pas d'autre chose voilà je m'amuse je
m'éclate et je travaille donc c'est
génial j'ai mal donc c'est une chance
[Musique]
airpod max on est d'accord que ça vaut
pas son prix même si on paye la marque
c'est un sujet compliqué et repose mac
ça marche très très bien
la qualité elle est folle
ils bossent vraiment vraiment bien ça
coûte cher ça baisse un peu je crois
mais ça coûte cher 1 mais ils sont tous
les pôles et un peu coûte cher
maintenant est ce que ça vaut pas son
prix tu te prends un w
je bouffe aidante w/h 1000 x n 3 mx 1 4
de sony qui paiera moins cher qui a très
très bien moi j'ai juste noté un truc un
peu un peu en dessous j'avais pas vu
avec mon test de des reposes max parce
que là j'ai pris l'avion quand je suis
parti à hawaï 11h le l'airpod mac sur
les oreilles au bout d'un moment tu peux
plus j'en pouvais plus à la fin j'avais
l'impression d'avoir d'espèces de
chausson qui me protège on pouvait plus
un peu et mal j'avais pas la même
sensation avec les
avec le casse-cou de sony la seule
différence c'est que je sentais pas le
morceau je sentais pas du tout parce
qu'avec ce tissu mesh qui est super bien
alors que j'avais un point de pression
avec sony voyez donc bon on peut pas
tout avoir
[Musique]
je trouve ça dommage que owen ne mettent
pas à jour le paie 30 light c'est
pourquoi j'ai eu aucune aucune info sur
les mises à jour je serai pas de dire
sans langue de bois penses tu que ce
qu'il se passe au sujet de huawei est
méritée quel avenir sur harmony os alors
est-ce que c'est mérité moi je suis je
ne peux pas le dire parce que cette
question de de sanctions américaines par
rapport à
des questions d'espionnage chinois je ne
sais pas je ne fais pas de géopolitique
je n'ai absolument aucune idée sur le
mérite ou pas le mérite par contre je
trouve ça intéressant parce que ça fait
émerger
comme on vient en fait dès le départ ce
qu'il faut voir c'est que huawei s'il
avait continué là où il en est et qui
serait probablement
passé peut-être numéro devant samsung
niveau mondial c'est pas impossible
parce qu'ils ont un hardware qui est
tellement dingue et il aurait fallu
améliorer encore l'expérience logiciel
mais hardware était tellement fou que je
pense qu'ils avaient tellement mis les
moyens qui seraient passés leader donc
ça leur a bien bien bien bien casser un
peu les pattes maintenant ils ont perdu
beaucoup de temps ils sont redescendus
ils misent à fond sur harmony os sur les
hms et sur la bière le riz et donc s'ils
arrivent à réussir leur pari pour
l'instant c'est intéressant honnêtement
il après il s'est tout un chacun il faut
voir si ça vous convient dans vos usages
mais s'ils arrivent à emmener tout ce
qu'on a en termes de d'application tout
ce qu'on va retrouver sur aujourd'hui
des smartphones avec les gms qu'on
retrouve dans quelques années
l'équivalent parfait et bien parfait sur
la braderie eh bien il va falloir
choisir entre du matériel et voir la
différence logiciel si ça pose problème
ou pas parce que c'est intéressant c'est
très intéressant donc pour moi ça ça
permet l'émergence d'une alternative ils
sont vraiment intéressants salue
monsieur grosse je suis plus sénégal
salut alpha j'aimerais savoir ce que tu
penses du de l'iphone
10r bien mais il a vieilli je
n'achèterai pas aujourd'hui il a vieilli
sauf si tu tous vraiment pas cher
toujours on est toujours en possession
de la ducati ouais elle est au garage
l'année héritage pour aion non je vais
pas lui laisser une vie moto idiote je
sais pas envie qu'ils fassent de la moto
était comble
iphone 8 plus en 2020 c'est un bon choix
tous pensent non je pense pas ça dépend
combien tu le payes c'est toujours une
question de budget ça coûte toujours
cher
benjamin ne dit salut tu peux être fier
de ton évolution est incroyable et j'ai
une petite question tu penses quoi du
renmin 10 s en tout cas bonne
continuation à toi
bien bien intéressant après une fois de
plus le renminbi 16 faut voir s'il
correspond à des usages
donc c'est truqué qu'il faut vraiment
vraiment voir iphone disent être
reconditionnés sur sarthe idylle en 2021
je veux pas à faire de la pub pour pour
une plateforme de reconditionner
d'ailleurs j'ai fait une vidéo sur un
parce que vous avez vues sur dur
conditionné j'allais visiter une usine
ya pas longtemps c'était super
intéressant j'étais fou en fait parce
que
quand on m'a proposé tient monsieur gros
vous défaire une collab avec toi et on
fait du reconditionnement et fait un
truc j'ai dit bon je vais pas faire une
énième vidéo pour durrrr conditionné a
expliqué reconditionnés expliqué voilà
on prend 20 smartphones reconditionne ya
deux ans de garantie non je dis non ok
mais je vais venir on va venir à la
maison et j'y suis allé c'est génial
parce qu'en fait je vais je j'ai
découvert j'ai jamais visité des usines
de reconditionner les c'était vraiment
c'est vraiment passionnant alors c'était
aller voir ma vidéo elle est en ligne
elle et je sais pas combien de vies
aujourd'hui mais on s'en fout du nom de
vue mais aller là bas parce qu'elle est
vachement intéressante parce que elle
montre comment ça marche dans l'usiné et
ça c'est un truc que j'ai adoré alors
envoyé pareil on se pose la question dix
ans à sin sponso ouais j'ai été payé
pour le faire ouais mais pour autant
génial peut-on avoir confiance en
téléphones reconditionnés c'est chez
smart que j'étais découvrons-le usine
smart aller la voir cette vidéo parce
qu'il est très très très cool on voit
comment ça marche on voit les process et
moi ce que j'ai adoré c'est que c'est
déjà en fête qui qui font tout local ils
font bosser des gens on puisse son
centre de formation qui forme des gens
alors ils les gardent pas tout ça mais
en fait ils recrutent leurs employés en
les formant comme ça tu vois très bien
si les mecs ça va le faire ou pas s'ils
ont envie s'ils apprennent
ils ont plusieurs enfin aller voir la
vidéo vous comprendrez j'ai trouvé ça
très très cool moi personnellement
et
j'ai vu que android ou s'étaient
suspendus sur galaxy s 21 c'est pourquoi
je sais pas du tout ce n'est pas du tout
ça
bon on va se faire le petit concours là
vous en pensez quoi vous êtes prêt ou
pas on va essayer de gagner on va
essayer je dis on va essayer de gagner
le au port et no 6 alors
je vous le dis je n'ai rien prévu je ne
sais pas comment on va faire donc on va
se le faire dans le tchat je vais vous
poser une question je vais vous poser on
va se faire ça comment je pense que je
vais vous poser une bonne question un
peu pourri le premier qui me donne la
bonne réponse
eh bien
je noterai son pseudo là et je dirais
c'est toi qui a gagné et il faudra
écoutez moi bien écoutez moi bien il
faudra m'envoyer un email en me disant
j'ai gagné tel smartphone et m'envoyer
une capture d'écran de votre youtube où
je vois bien que c'est votre pseudo que
c'est bien vous essayez ça parce que je
veux pas voir la petite arnaque du genre
oui c'est moi et c'est pas moi en fait
donc je veux vraiment être sûr donc il
faudra faire ça je pense que là on est
on est pas mal ok alors on se concentre
laissez moi réfléchir
laissez-moi trouver un truc un peu un
peu funky pour vous faire gagner ça
on a deux smartphones à faire gagner
soir le au port no6 et le au port no6
pro hockey coucou nous dit vincent salut
vincent
alors je vais pas vous trouver des trucs
trop mer 2 mais je vais
faire appel je pense dans un premier
temps à votre réactivité et votre
rapidité
est-ce que vous êtes prêts je viens au
message vous êtes faudrait pas prêt
attention parce que on a au parc rimbaud
smartphones à gagner on parle pas de
n'importe quoi
est ce que vous y êtes
tintin pinpin
je vois que il ya du monde ok ok là on
se concentre ok d'accord ok
ok
alors attention vous êtes prêts bon ok
on va partir la première personne
bien la première personne qui me marque
dans le tchat
écoutez bien vous y êtes en voyage est
la première personne qui dans le chat ne
marque
le titre exact
de ma première vidéo faite sur au pot
remporte le au port et nos six pros
attention c'est parti le titre exact
de ma première vidéo sur au pot là je
vous sens au tac hausse la première
tension
je regarde je suis hyper concentrés là
je vois beaucoup de hockey très près
égaux attention je veux le titre exact
j'attends
je veille je regarde
alors je les peins
le titre exact
nom de ma toute première vidéo sur au
pot 1
je veux le titre exact de ma toute
première vidéo faite sur ma chaîne
youtube sur au pot
non c'est pas dr vince et désigne comme
ça c'est autre chose de ma première
vidéo sur au pot
à attendait est-ce qu'on a quelque chose
non non non
non aïe aïe aïe on les a pas on les a
peints
à anla c'est david top a été c'est de la
ville david lefebvre david au pot arrive
en france et va présenter les finepix
voilà hockey david c'est pour toi je le
note alors david
je note un parce que en plus c'est
pratique c'est un nom de famille comme
ça au moins on va pas se planter david
tu m'envoies un email
dans lequel tu me fais une capture
d'écran de ton youtube je vais être sûr
que c'est toi ton pseudo ta photo bref
tu mon va tout ça tu m'envoies un email
tu m'envoies ton adresse donc nom prénom
adresse postale
numéro de téléphone c'est pas pour moi
je vais pas les conserver c'est juste
pour que au popiste envoyé le smartphone
donc tu m'envoies sa capture d'écran je
veux être sûre que ce soit toi
tu peux m'en vais autant de trucs que tu
veux en en pièce jointe pour être sûr
que c'est toi
nom prénom numéro de téléphone adresse
et bravo david tu as gagné 1 au port est
lui aussi stable
cela veut dire presque bon forcément
voilà j'applaudis bravo enfin comme
s'ils avaient d'autres réponses à de
bonnes réponses 1 puisque attendez
attendez à temps il faut que je remonte
quand même parce que j'en ai
quelques-uns mais
non on pourrait nous non non
non non on and on a envoyé
18 astuces je regarde mes à hope au
finepix d'eau pro le smartphone venu du
futur non non non
non non non hop
et ben non tu vois tu es le seul à
l'avoir eu un
c'est fou c'est incroyable incroyable
que tu sois le seul à l'avoir sorti
incroyable l'asam scotch complet parce
que ça me paraissait paf pas hyper dur
il suffit d'aller sur sur ma chaîne est
de rechercher au pot et de remonter la
liste ou de faire un classement est ok
et ben écoute félicitations
on va faire autrement pour la deuxième
question
c'est un montant il y en a pas mal de
bravo david up hockey et il good game
and good game goodgame honte marque je
suis complètement d'accord goodgame
trop cool alors attendez ouais non bah
écoute et voilà donc félicitations david
david tu m'envoies ça vite vite vite
comme ça moi je transfère à au pot et
puis je me sens tout pouvoir vérifier
que c'est bien toi donc
envoie moi ça et puis on ne s'est créée
à sa bien évidemment
t'as pas une playlist précises en même
temps non mais ya pas qu'à playlist
parce que si tu vas sur la chaîne
youtube tu dois pouvoir le voir
directement
si tu vas sur ma chaîne regarde je vais
te montrer
on va aller sur ma chaîne on va aller
sur ma chaîne arte régionaux m comme ça
navigateur voilà ça c'est ma chaîne
coucou tout le monde donc en fait quand
tu vas sur ma chaîne
si tu fais une recherche juste avec rupo
et que tu peux pas les trier as tu peux
pas faire tri hausse est relou away dont
font remonter faut remonter pour monter
il faut remonter les proches du rythme
au
jeu comprend pourquoi vous faire monter
comme un sauvage ah ouais
ok bon et ben tu sais quoi félicitations
david que c'est tellement relou en fait
c'est ce qu'on appelle de
l'impréparation va écoute tu vois tu la
sortie donc félicitations parce que
ouais en fait moi je le voyais bien sûr
pour
les sketches à deux balles moi je le
voyais bien en fait sûrement sur mon
ma partie à moi creator studio donc
voilà bon bah écoute bravo david parce
que c'était vraiment pas vraiment pas
évident
hop là attendez je reviens de ce côté là
bon ok
aïe aïe aïe
c'était pas hyper évident pas hyper
évident bon ok on va faire mieux pour le
pour la deuxième le deuxième ça sera le
au port et nos six pros donc on va
regarder comment on peut faire ça on va
se le faire dans quelques instants on se
prend encore un petit peu de temps comme
ça on est tranquille jeux en bois un
petit coup vous voulez boire un coup ou
n'est pas un bon un petit coup comprenez
vous vous un petit verre ou pas
prenez-vous en hiver
tu as quel âge khalaji est ton ami les
cheveux blancs
aux messages
allez on va faire un truc plus simple je
vais essayer de faire beaucoup beaucoup
plus simple pour le
pour le réno syspro
en train de réfléchir déjà ce que je
vous propose je réfléchis on en parle
dans on se fait le deuxième concours dit
si je sais pas moi 20 minutes une demi
heure j'en sais rien on va voir on va
pouvoir garder pour l'instant on reste à
la
merci
cyril t pour l'affectation pour ces cinq
cent mille abonnés est trop cool on nous
dit 23 ans moi j'ai pas 23 ans alors
c'est moi j'aurais sacrément gonflé
je te raconte pas l'histoire 42 g 42
c'est ça 42 on y est 18h18 vraiment fait
38 ans serait encore possible 35 on
passerait 44 salles aux familles
chevallier et 44 39 10 38 44
55 ça c'est pas très sympa
tu es quand même moins nerveux en live
barry un moment est forcément mais mais
en fait c'est vraiment mon truc je suis
toujours un brin toujours speed donc ce
que vous voyez dans les vidéos c'est pas
c'est pas c'est pas un mensonge je suis
très speed mais c'est vrai que c'est pas
pourquoi devenue la caméra c'est sa part
encore plus mais là sur le live je
tiendrai pas deux heures comme ça je
pense que je serai puiser avant donc
vous voyez
donc on va y aller tranquille une canne
aide et d'argile rico et non moi je ne
peux pas les boissons énergisantes ne
supporte pas tout ce qui va être
kaffrine déjà tu me tues donc tu me
donnes le reste je tient pas longtemps
bonjour monsieur greuet ce que tu passe
de bonnes vacances et est ce que tu
comptes reprend lève twitch en janvier
tous les jours alors pas tous les jours
mais je vais en refaire en janvier
d'élèves tweet je pense que premier live
tweet qu'on le fera on le fera en direct
de de las vegas et comme il ya un
décalage horaire et ben je sais pas quel
moment on sera mais on se fera un
extrait du pv ça va être cool
un autre jeu enfin notre jeu à qui
devinerait le premier ton âge ouais
ouais
ah j'ai vu passer un message de
jinta jinta qui est présent sur sur
twitch sait plus où les messages ça
bouge tellement vite ce chat que ricoré
[Musique]
pour t'avoir rencontré en vrai se
confirme que tu expliques tu m'as tu
vois c'est vrai tu l'as vu un jugement
par
reprend du propranolol dont je veux pas
non donc je peux éviter j'y vais pas
hyper activité
je sais pas je pense pas beaucoup vive
la république et vive la france
quand tu lances les boîtes de téléphone
et ouais c'est vrai que ça c'est un peu
mon truc lancé les bottes de telles
fausses gars parce que je casse quand
même jour je sais pas pourquoi mais je
fais ça
félicitations bateau millions j'espère
j'aimerais tellement on verra si ça
arrive un monsieur drevet tant que coo
d'abidjan salut coucou abidjan
3e concours un billet là un billet las
vegas non ce nom quand même pas
40 ans tu les fais larcher
est ce que tu pourrais faire live tweet
ch pour le nouvel an non pour nous
verrons alors je te lis pour nouvel an
je vais le faire avec des potes
tranquille ou bisous je vais me poser
peinarde ozcan ardoz je vais me détendre
je vais être hyper zen et par contre je
sais pas quand est ce que je vais faire
les promesses faites là ce que je suis
en train de faire pour tout vous dire
tout de suite là maintenant tout
certaines femmes à l'action et vous
l'avez vu je suis là par contre ce qui
est prévu c'est que là je suis en train
de me faire mes petits tableaux la main
molle en quête de quoi je vais parler
c'est les prochaines de quelle manière
je vais changer plein de trucs il
fallait tout super sympa enfin juste
pour moi j'espère qu'on verra si ça vous
plaît toujours aux pas de la de teck
soyez tranquilles et en fait j'ai dit
alors qu'elle moi je vais réussir à quai
sont aplanies à quelques mois je vais
aussi rétro laquelle moi je vais faire
ça mon gros problème c'est que j'ai
envie de faire quinze mille trucs et qui
a pris à la réalité voilà le problème il
est là mais comme là y'a plus les
montages je vais pouvoir récupérer mes
quinze mille trucs donc bon on va
structurer sa mais ouais j'ai trop envie
de faire trop de trucs vous rigoler
tellement de choses à faire c'est la
tête qui t'excite toi je suis un peu
chaud chaud avec moi d'ailleurs tu
penses que amazon va refaire cette
émission car c'était cool comme concept
affaire à suivre affaire à suivre
s'est moqué des quarante deux premiers
je pense ça là c'est pas la question
pour avoir le le au port et nos six pros
l'histoire boulons non non non non non
je te suis depuis le début quelle
évolution merci beaucoup à kim
monsieur gauthier fait 38 en un jeu m'a
écouté c'est gentil c'est le filtre pas
de filtre salut arthur qui vient
d'arriver également quand metz vous de
rin aussi qu'en penser que pensez-vous
de rhinau chine je pense ben moi
rhinochill j'aime bien regarder si
j'allais faire ma coque je vais faire ma
coque monsieur brochet eux alors c'est
une coque unique 1 c'est moi qui les
fabriquent et pour moi mais j'aime bien
les matériaux ils sont très bons en fait
rino si ça marche bien ils font des
belles protection je préfère la
protection de
d'apple la coque d'apple native des
trouve un peu plus légère et en termes
de prise en main je les aime bien mais
les coques de rhinau si je trouve très
cool et j'aime bien le j'aime bien le
fait qu'on puisse personnaliser alors on
va pas en faire des tartines sponsorise
pas le live mais je vous lis en tout le
temps toute transparence
alors anas je vois que tu mais depuis
tout à l'heure la question de l'iphone
disent être conditionnel certes idées en
2021 l'iphone 10 aces il a commencé à
vieillir c'est toujours une question de
budget certes idylle ou passera t il peu
importe mais pourquoi pas en tout cas un
iphone 10s si tu le veux mais c'est une
question de budget mais pour moi il ya
commence à vieillir en photo
bon déjà bonsoir ça lui dis moi l'ami
power band 3 pro coûte 80 euros au lieu
de 50 et elle se fait très rare tu sais
pourquoi et pourquoi pas faire une vidéo
dessus elle est superbe
jésus connais pas ce produit bon alors
ce que je dis dans le titre je crois
comprendre un peu de quoi on parle mais
il ya plein de produits très cool et je
peux pas malheureusement parler tout
mais non je ne sais pas du tout tu me
lis 80 au lieu de 50 ça me paraît dingue
je sais pas je ne ferai pas de dire je
serai pas dire du tout pensez quoi du
wan +9 fromage est bien aimé le one + 9
pro
j'avais bien aimé vous ont progressé en
photo et je trouve très beau un très
joli produit donc pourquoi pas
il y avait une question là
tu achète les produits tels que tu
présentes en vidéo ou tulle et possède
grâce à des partenariats ça m'a toujours
intéressé à a alors non les marques me
les envoie je les achète pas il m'est
déjà arrivé d'acheter les produits mais
c'est très rare très rare la plupart du
temps c'est des marques qui les envoie
donc voila et plupart du temps ils les
récupèrent leur pour tout vous dire
mon problème avec la cokerie nos chine
sur le sbf eux ils le découvrent ah
ouais abbas jamais vu ça
plus de 400 euros pour réparer un p 40
prochain huawei qu'en penses-tu est
400 balles pour réparer un smartphone au
sein de parieurs de prix à 420 est un
smartphone d'un autre smartphone 9 je
suis tout ça je trouve ça cher après ça
dépend je sais pas on trouve ça très
cher mois 400 euros jeu je me dis 400
euros jamais pas pour et par un
smartphone alain picard en pro je suis
sûr que tu peux le trouver en
reconditionnés moins cher on cautionnait
war en oeuvre qu'on m'écoute aujourd'hui
je n'ai pas comme les coutures du p 40
pro fait voir dans un truc qui
m'intéresse
mais 40 pro si je veux acheter je
trouves tu vois là j'en ai un
reconditionnés bac market à 439 euros
non 756 reste encore un peu cher mais
non moi je fais je suis dur conditionné
je fais pas réparé ouais je sais pas ça
me paraît fou quoi faire il faut voir il
faut voir mes chers
e
[Musique]
on pense quoi du macbook air est main et
sa durée de vie
moi j'ai beaucoup aimé la performance
la durée de vie
je n'ai pas testé pendant des années
pour dire j'ai pas le recul tu vois pour
une durée de vie d'un ordinateur donc la
question ça va être compliqué de 2,2
très pauvre en fait mais ce qui est sûr
c'est que cette puce m 1 il ya un gain
de performances et d'autonomie qui
étouffe par rapport aux générations
intel donc
intéressant
intéressant est ce que tu connais dijon
monsieur bré ouais j'y suis allé
plusieurs fois disons pour travailler à
l'époque où je travaillais pas sur ma
chaîne youtube je connais disons assez
balle mais je connais dijon
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu penses du bo find x3o
vous êtes nombreux à en parler soit
toujours intéressant les fans extra neo
est ce que tu as des bons plans
smartphones tous mes bons plans je
voulais partager vous les connaissez
tous tu as fait quoi comme études moi
j'ai fait l'étude de la vie dont j'ai eu
un bac 1 bac en fait je me suis
vachement chercher je me suis cherché
j'ai fait une fac d'histoire jets de
galets trois semaines une fac d'anglais
j'ai dû y aller une semaine j'ai fait
une formation de musicien professionnel
ça dure un an j'ai fait un stage au bout
de six mois et je suis resté après dans
mon stage et j'ai commencé à travailler
dans le monde du spectacle était
assistant studio ensuite je commence à
travailler en live en concert début je
poussais des caisses et puis je me suis
formée en concert j'étais technicien
sont en même temps je faisais de la
radio nationale en parallèle et puis
j'ai rencontré des gens un pote qui
avait un site web je rencontrais qui est
venu un pote sur les sorties loisirs à
clermont on a bossé ensemble là dessus
j'ai arrêté tout le reste on se lancer
dans l'entrepreneuriat
j'ai eu à organiser des salons des
événements mille et un trucs ensuite
j'ai fait une vae pour valider un master
2 par rapport à ce que j'avais fait j'ai
envie d'avoir un diplôme en fait sur
toute mon expérience
voilà j'ai fait du marketing en
pharmacie j'ai fait des millions truc et
puis voilà aujourd'hui c'est rigolo
ça n'a rien à voir
[Musique]
quel smartphone qui m'ont fait autour de
300 euros j'ai fait une vidéo là dessus
quel smartphone à moins de 500 euros va
jeter un petit coup d'oeil liège je ne
connais pas je ne suis jamais allé
raynaud six pros du coup on va en parler
du réno 6 prend par ailleurs à en parler
un peu de calme les amis dit donc on
n'est quand même pas trop pressé
monsieur oui j'ai une question ça va
quelques mois que j'ai un beau zen ses
700 way et je voulais savoir si j'étais
le seul à qui son cas se déconnecte tout
le temps et est ce que t'as une solution
alors moins tout de suite je te dirai je
ne sais pas parce que quand je les
jeunes utilisent pas depuis un petit
moment le
le700 mais je
tuais depuis quelques mois est-ce qu'il
n'est pas encore sous garantie tu vois
postaux la question va vouloir poser la
question va contacter boss directement
je pense que ceux qui sauront mieux tu
réponds pour moi tu me dis un quinze qui
se déconnectent régulièrement est ce que
c'est normal pour moi non c'est pas
normal donc tu as une garantie 2 ans sur
les produits contact bonne voie avec eux
et essayent de résoudre ce problème
parce qu'il ya pas de raison ton casque
ne fonctionne pas
pourquoi tu t'es spécialise en latex sur
youtube doute est venue cette idée
depuis que je suis gamin j'adore la tech
je sais pas pourquoi en fait je sais pas
d'où c'est venu je sais pas j'arrive pas
à remonter loin j'ai me rappelle mon
promet je voulais un ordinateur j'étais
petite personne dans ma famille
s'intéresse à sa personne ce n'est pas
de dire qu'il y avait un homme très très
stéréotypé moi j'ai vécu qu'avec des
femmes donc je n'ai pas de schéma tu vas
te pourrir pas un père qui est passionné
de teck qui avait un qui voulait un
vieil ordinateur tu sais papa jamais et
que ce soit ma soeur ma mère ou ma
grand-mère ou mais mon arrière grand
mère à l'époque personne était passionné
tech donc je sais pas d'où ça m'est venu
de vouloir un ordinateur je sais pas
j'ai fait ce que je suis majestueuse
acheter des revues à ma mère quand
j'étais petit c'est des revues des
magazines on dire vieux à l'époque en
1980 et quelques
jeux ça me passionnait donc j'avais fait
acheter un vieil amstrad à cassette je
mettais une demi-heure à charger les
jeux le cpc 464
je sais pas pourquoi j'ai adoré ça et
puis les consoles j'ai joué aux consoles
il est quand j'ai vu les ordinateurs pc
grand public y arriver je vois ça génial
je préfère avec l'ouverture au monde et
surtout quand internet est arrivé j'ai
fait au nom de dieu qu'est-ce qu'on va
prendre dans la tronche ah ben je
n'étais pas loin j'étais loin de bomber
pourquoi mais non c'est génial génial je
ne vais pas vous dire pourquoi j'aime ça
il est très bizarre comme ça en fait
j'ai pas à ce que j'ai vu un magazine
dans petit je me suis transposer je sais
pas
salut à
sony courra salue monsieur gros coucou
que penses tu de la peinture ripolin
temps posé question bob l'eponge toi je
te jure tu fais du code informatique au
sinon je suis je jubile je peux lire un
peu de phpstorm de maremne et je sais
rien faire je suis une [ __ ] complet
cfoot est clairement je suis au campus
des cézeaux abx a laissé aux j'allais me
balader là bas quand j'étais petit je
n'étais pas loin des cézeaux quand
j'étais gamin tous les dimanches savait
faire du vélo c'est bon ça a un peu
changé quand même depuis un et puis à
quand j'étais à la fac j'allais à la bd
c'est aussi et je mangeais il ya un gros
show c'est au moyen crous mais ce
n'était pas terrible je mangeais pas
celui là mais oui le campus des cézeaux
je connais très très bien j'ai fait des
soirées là bas il y avait lisima forget
fait des soirées à lisima
l'isi must et l'école d'ingénieurs en
informatique je crois j'ai fait des
soirées là bas je veux tellement de fois
au nota bene c'est encore ce petit bar
sur le campus nota bene
s'ils ont sévi micro ouais j'adore
l'aller tout ce qui est aussi science un
taux qui me passionne on peut pas parler
tout moment faire des choix c'est beau
ce que tu fais aider les gens à me
connaître le texte un merci beaucoup
abdel
que qu'est ce que tu penses de linux je
le suis pas je n'utilise pas linux donc
je n'ai pas de je peux pas t'en répondre
que penses tu du vita mais h du matin tu
fais ta mère
du metavers ce je trouve personnellement
c'est un sujet passionnant way
passionnant effrayant je peux comprendre
il faut voir mon rêve c'est d'avoir un
bon smartphone n'ayant pas les moyens
j'aimerais bien me le faire offrir et
ben reste connecté parce qu'on va
bientôt jouer pour le rémo six pros je
suis depuis janvier 2017 ou walt la
vache la première vidéo de toi que j'ai
vu c'était une vidéo pour perdre du
poids
j'étais un gros depuis j'ai loupé aucune
de tes vidéos où tu as vu ça et ça a
changé la ligne l édito depuis hier en
fait quand j'ai commencé à faire ma
chaîne youtube c'est l extension de mon
blog et dans mon blog j'écrivais tout et
n'importe quoi surtout n'importe quoi et
du coup je me suis dit sur youtube un je
m'ennuyais à écrire des articles puis ça
fonctionnait pas je m'ennuyais toupie
j'ai un pote qui m'a dit mais moi je
fais des vidéos sur youtube tu dois
regarder mon pote arnaud 4h à amos et il
m'a dit regarde et du coup j'ai regardé
acheter un bouquin que youtube comment
ça marche pied de comprendre et j'ai vu
un créateur qui parler cuisine et de
stages dit c'est quoi ce mec j'ai google
et youtube ise peut dire ça comme ça
j'ai pris une gifle je dis je veux ça
c'est ça que je veux alors on en était
loin on l'a fait il toujours très très
loin mais j'ai adoré une vraie source
d'inspiration et
et donc j'ai fait plein de vidéos sur
des trucs qui n'ont rien à voir avec ce
que je fais aujourd'hui mais ça me
faisait marrer voilà mais bon voilà et
je crois qu'il a encore de ces vidéos
qui qui qui qui ont marché je sais pas
si elles seront accessibles j'en ai j'en
ai planté quelques unes parce
qu'aujourd'hui il ya des sujets qui
fâchent les gens alors que c'est ce
qu'on met attend en effet de voir les
plus récentes visibilité vu comment je
peux faire voir les plus anciennes est
ce que je peux
tak tak les plus récentes par défaut non
attends triés par
alors je vais là c'est peut-être ça l'a
peut-être sa
vue - de vue non je le regardais ici
qu'est ce que j'avais attendez je vais
vous dire ça me fait tellement rire sur
ma chaîne youtube
mais vidéo
alors attendez j'ai regardé en même
temps c'est pour ça que je suis un peu
j'ai un peu un petit peu long à la
détente jeux med sur mon dashboard et je
vais vous je vois donné les thèmes
ça rame un peu ça rame sa ram ça rame
contenu
filtre comment je peux faire non c'est
pas ça c'est le tri la criée pas alors
attends date voilà date d'un
haut que ces vieux tout ça alors en fait
voici bio c'est vieux c'est vieux j'ai
une vieille interview stromae que j'ai
dégagé j'avais rencontré stromae ça mec
super gentil première vidéo je marche
sur un lac gelé voilà le 16 décembre
2016 je me rappelle je lire fait quinze
fois cette vidéo avant d'être content
quinze fois j'avais fait une vidéo elle
est plus accessible aujourd'hui
s'appelle je regarde des fesses toute la
journée c'est un blog en fait et en fait
j'ai viré parce que je me suis dit en
fait les gens n'est pas comprend en fait
j'étais en train de faire le site
internet d'une copine qui est sexologue
et je suis allé l'aider dans le blog on
voit les l'aider et s'est vu tout ça
ensuite j'ai fait quoi ce vin est fait
par un druide
397 vu 18 décembre 2016
397 vue faut dire que ça n'avait aucun
intérêt une vidéo je vais un match de
l'asm mille vue
[Musique]
ouais j'avais fait quand même dix ans
qu'un peu un peu un peu con con j'ai
mangé une star du top 50 731 vu ça c'est
encore visibles c'est un pote à moi qui
a qui est chanteur d'un groupe qui
s'appelle wenzhou est qui avait fait une
chanson qui avait cartonné à une époque
et ont toujours encore donc voyez il ya
plein de petits trucs comme ça j'avais
fait une vidéo ces petits moments qui
comptent où j'étais avec ma famille on
faisait de la grande roue clermont je
crois 253 vue et puis après j'ai parlé
de l'apple watch series 2 5700 vue
5 remède contre la gueule de bois 1135
vu ça marche encore ce truc tu sais pas
pourquoi
[Musique]
ouais je regarde
face et voilà c'était c'était s'étaient
étalés tout comme sujet mais ça me
faisait rire quoi
ça me faisait rien c'est un peu ridicule
en fait mais trouve ça drôle c'est
marrant de regarder un pas en arrière
quoi
silva basse me dit pour moi tu fais
partie des youtuber avec des vidéos très
complète dans ton domaine tu as une
référence pour les tests high tech avec
pépé world merci beaucoup et merci pour
pépé que j'adore cleppé soit dit en
passant
florentin audi salue monsieur re salut à
toi
bravo en dégringolade l'asm en ce moment
c'est un peu compliqué tu arrives à bien
tr/min rec taschen oui j'ai pas un plein
de frédéric
en quoi est il bien serait nocif
histoire me faire languir tout le monde
alors lorraine aussi c'est bien le réno
syspro est très bien aussi il est une
vidéo faut aller voir les vidéos si tu
vois pas les vidéos tu te sépares tu vas
voir les vidéos tu le sauras comme ça on
te voit beaucoup parlé de téléphone
audio tablettes ordinateurs portables
mais on ne voit jamais parlé de tout ce
qui est pc fixes gamer est ce qu'on
verra un jour par être pacifique et
marne non je pense pas je pense pas
parce que c'est toi mon pote arnaud il
va te parler de ça davantage moi je ne
suis pas un gamer donc je peux pas te
parler de conte de config gamer montée
des pc-7 jamais été mon truc de monter
les pc moi j'aime quand les produits
sont finis j'aime pas les montées je
vais pas mettre les mains dedans en fait
d'un pc je veut dire oise où j'ai
l'album je trouve encore la manivelle
voilà on y est que penses tu du nouveau
des l'inspiron qu'un je n'ai pas testé
j'aurais pas te répondre
je souhaite acheter un pc aux alentours
2003 milan déjà un sacré budget pourrais
tu m'aider faire le choix j'hésite pour
l'informatique va voir mon pote arnaud
s'est tu vas le voir il est sur un stade
il est sur youtube arnaud le prénom
c'est cette juste à l'aide s'est tu vas
lui poser la question il va te répondre
parce que il est hyper calais et hugo
complète des engagés aux geôles aussi
mais vous j'adore aussi monsieur greuze
je me pose la question en train s vingt
et un autres disent plus lequel le
conseiller
[Musique]
où
moi je te dirais le s20 clermont
génération d'après puis une autre 10
plus le style et je m'intéresse pas trop
tu connais la radio libre de difool
j'écoutais dif ou quantité sur fun radio
il ya longtemps oui je connais j'aime
bien ce mec c'est un mec que j'aime bien
et que je respecte vraiment dans son
métier énormément mois pendant sa sur la
dérive elle et je voulais acheter un pc
fixe pour tout ce qui est 3d gaming vous
allez voir mon pote arnaud également
pour tous qui va être pc séduit qui veut
vraiment orienté
est-ce que je suis ami rémy ne distingue
mon premier smartphone moi bien sûr
salut poteau salut poteau je souhaite
acheter un galaxy folle de trois avis
please très bon smartphone form-factor
différent très belles bêtes que tu peux
utiliser avec un stylet why notes sur la
productivité j'adore je me prends un
petit verdot une trente secondes et je
suis à vous parce que je finis à
grenadines j'arrive
je m'entraîne pas séché en fait à
ça serait dommage de s'assécher quand
même
est-ce que tu serais prêt at éloigné de
la tête pour d'autres vidéos mais je
pense oui mais je ne suis pas sûr qu'on
serait prêt à me à me suivre pour
d'autres vidéos j'en sais rien en fait
et toutes les plateformes se le dise si
tu veux c'est que quand tu fus dans un
sujet reste aussi parce que tu perds les
gens et il ya des trucs dont j'aimerais
vous parler mais je me dis est ce qu'il
faudrait une chaîne secondaire autre
chose j'en sais rien mais là j'ai
tellement déjà sous la halle tout ce que
j'ai à faire que si je fais ça
je sais pas c'est un homme né mais ouais
y'a plein de trous dans gmail ou pas le
plein
dr vince yes j'adore dr vince des
polyvalents quoi si tu connais dr vince
rubens dr vince faisait de la radio
associative avec lui il ya longtemps à
radio revers à clermont j'ai connu là
bas vince pépé est super sympa rencontré
au salon hifi à paris pp c'est une crème
absolue salue monsieur grrrr franchement
façon pressante en harmonie merci
beaucoup personnellement je suis depuis
compter sur le chiot mire et demi note 6
pro 3 ans un petit moment
t'as plus les vidéos c'est quand il
marche sur un lac gelé c'est
ccpp vince où je sais plus quoi je
marche sur un lac gelé c'était ma toute
première vidéo que j'ai fait avec le ch
ou un blog ou des biens blog quotidien
bon c'était pas ce qu'elle sait pas quel
pattes à un canard mais c'était une
super expérience ça m'a appris en fait à
devoir tourner tous les jours déjà mais
j'adorais c'est un peu léger en ce
moment les nouveautés ben forcément ils
sortent moins une chose en ce moment il
ya moins d'actu parce que le gros de
l'actus était surtout vers octobre donc
là ça se calme ça repartira l'année
prochaine un début de l'année ça va
commencer avec le cs les annonces et
voit sauter quand
je montre le passé de pêche de 15 ans et
mathé
bravo c'est pas mon truc du tout tu
devrait recommander ton pote sur sa
chaîne youtube
ouais
c'est vrai que ce fait pas ça est ce que
je vois je vais regarder je vais
regarder sentir un certain raison sans
doute intéressant salut aurélien tu as
fait des vidéos sympas sur les véhicules
électriques penses-tu enfin sur les
motos et rixes et 1 1 c'est un monde de
paix qui alors en fait je fais des
vidéos sur les véhicules connectés parce
qu'une connectivité si je trouve qu'il
ya un sens intéressante au niveau de la
la connectivité sur des motos ouais on
pourrait en parler s'il n'ya pas
connecté ça juste pour paris de motos
électriques je suis pas sûr que c'est là
dessus qu'on m'attende
tu es unique et j'apprends beaucoup sur
toi tout ce qui est téléphone et toutes
eu explique très bien je suis marocain
veut pas de toi merci beaucoup et
bonjour à tous nos amis du maroc
super cool merci je râle un peu vos
messages là j'adore répondre à vos
messages ça c'est ça que je veux faire
les live à homps lit on regarde ce qui
se passe aulas il ya plein de messages
que j'ai loupé la
tête
niveau de teck à ton avis chine où ils s
abat les deux les deux les deux mon
lapin
et tu toujours vote avec mathieu dos
santos d'andromaque sur watch
actuellement la chaîne oui bien sûr mais
suivront avec mathieu alors on s'est vus
il ya deux mois trois mois avec mathieu
ils étaient venus ils étaient mieux la
maison
sur le nouveau studio tout intérêt à la
mobilité électrique giroud trop de vélo
d'olt temps en temps j'aime bien en
parler c'est celui de temps en temps
merci pour tes contenu tu es très
ascendante et vidéo ça fait plaisir et
on parcourt semble ressemble au mien
sauf que je ne suis pas youtube a
peut-être que tu vas devenir va savoir
quel iphone acheté à moins de 500 euros
ça peut être une caisse apparaître une
vidéo intéressante
salue monsieur grrrr franchement
filiation pour 5000 abonnés je te suis
depuis lé début des têtes merci beaucoup
tu sois comme ordinateur j'ai un macbook
pour la salle le 16 pouces là mais c'est
la version intel parce que j'ai un
plugin qui fonctionne pas encore avec le
m1 mais il est là le juste à côté
le temps passe à côté
bonsoir monsieur greuze j'aimerais
savoir si tu testes experian mark iii se
répandant sur la chaîne alors le xperia
de marque 3 je les lui j'ai toujours
d'ailleurs je les ai testés j'ai fait
des choses mais j'ai pas fait de vidéo
dessus
je trouve intéressant je trouve
extrêmement intéressant mais je continue
à penser que sony est encore un peu
pointu après ils ont vraiment la
démarche et c'est ce qui est intéressant
mais il faudrait que j'en parle plus
tard ça tout de suite je sais pas il
faut que je finisse de de digérer des
choses sony ils font un vrai photophone
qui fait des vraies photos voyez on
n'est pas dans un poteau phone avec de
l'ia qui va trop moduler pour que on
nous sortent ça devienne sur flatteur si
bien que lorsque on sait pas trop faire
de photos alors vous avez un mode
automatique mais on peut rapidement
perdre un peu dans ces paramètres quand
on voit dans les paramètres manuel mais
après on se pose aux boutiques ça marche
mais je trouve ça intéressant ce qu'ils
font parce que ils font différent des
autres et c'est peut-être ce qui leur
permettra de continuer à exister mais
c'est sûr que pour l'instant c'est un
peu compliqué
tu regardes pas le père noël est une
ordure tu l'a peu vu peut-être hd vu
quelquefois j'adore ce film fait
toujours rire
[Musique]
tu conserver quoi en train d un terrain
pixels
621,3 une bonne bière pas ce soir mais à
une prochaine phase plaisir je les bus
hier soir combien de temps peut-on
garder un smartphone android pour moi
deux à trois ans sans problème trois ans
tu peux y aller ça dépend du smartphone
monsieur greuet ce que ton ancien local
studio tu l'a revendu le le studio où on
voyait avec le fond bleu lavoyer et
c'est là en fait c'est là mais j'ai tout
péter donc c'est cette pièce là ici mais
tout était pété en fait toute la pièce
donc ça se passe là et j'avais un autre
studio à paris
lui par contre je l'ait rendue pour
prendre mon nouveau nouveau local salut
amicaux qui viennent d'arriver
tu as le matos et tout pour le live fu
live plus souvent je ferai des lives
plus souvent mais je le ferai sur tweets
je pense donc rejoignez moi sur twitter
pour live monsieur gros franchement
c'est à cent pour cent mille abonnés
merci à toi
[Musique]
c'est quoi ton passe temps favori si tu
écris ça je ne fais dites vous bien il
ya je fais deux choses dans la vie un
youtube ce que je fais là youtube
twitter mon travail ça et puis ma
famille il ya rien d'autre parce qu'il
n'y a pas de place pour autre chose ce
que j'ai envie de faire depuis des
années c'est de prendre du temps à
refaire de la musique mais j'ai pas tant
donc quand j'aurai du temps je pressens
pour l'instant c'est pas toi est-ce que
tu penses à magna est ce que tu penses
que samsung doivent faire son propre os
comme apple non je ne pense pas
c'est quoi ton passe temps favori en
combien de voix tu n'as tu n'as pas pu
avoir d'invités pour s en cachent en
fait ketchup il vrai pour tout dire et
coucou à toi je t'ai pas vu un
vu la situation actuelle je j'évite de
voir du monde parce que je parle
normalement dans dix jours direction les
us donc là c'est fait hyper gaffe à
qui
je peux dire à qui je vois c'est pas
vrai parce que j'ai plein de potes j'ai
envie de les voir mais c'est trop
compliqué à cause du colline donc si je
veux pas me retrouver avec le variant
qui flambe de partout à risquer de me
trouver qu'à contacter ou même moi même
infecté je vais y faire gaffe donc je
vois donc je peux être que plus tard
pour les 600 me où j'en sais rien quand
ça arrivera si la situation le permet
peut-être qu'on se rencontre avec plein
de potes ça serait ça serait marrant
j'aimerais bien faire
quel est ton pc préféré chez huawei
le met debout x est très cool
je crois que c'est celui là que
j'utilise à la maison
merci pour tes vidéos se souhaite de
bonnes fêtes de fin d'année merci à tous
les manuels jj on va se faire le
concours dans quelques instants un jeu
garde encore
regardé il est quoi il est déjà 22
heures hall là ça fera bientôt deux
heures qu'on est ensemble
on va se faire le concours dure et nos
six pros dans quelques instants
je réfléchis en fait à ce que je peux
vous proposer tristesse j'avais pas vu
le live mais nico tu pourras le regarder
après t'inquiète pas et on est encore
ensemble inquiète pas qu'est-ce que tu
rêves de réaliser sur sa chaîne youtube
des produits partenariat fit
en fait ce que je veux sur ma chaîne
youtube c'est que toutes mes vidéos
soient différentes
voilà
et ça demande beaucoup de travail donc
on va saluer monsieur greu après huit
mois maintenant que le one + 9 pro est
sorti me le conseil que wayne toujours
intéressant voire plus neuf pros talent
et mises à jour de sécurité qui vont
durer longtemps tu as les mises à jour
bien évidemment d'android c'est un bel
appareil pour moi y'a encore cool tu t'y
soit comme ordinateur j'ai répondu
quelle est la pire vidéo que tu es
tourner la pire vidéo où j'ai tourné à
j'ai dû en avoir des pires vidéo
je saurai pas de dire
j'arrive pas être satisfait tu vois mes
vidéos maison à celle là les géniales
mais très content je dis assez bien je
suis content et puis je le regarde deux
mois après je dis ah non ça plutôt comme
ça donc je de la même manière que j'ai
pas vraiment pire vidéo j'ai pas de
meilleure vidéo
je sais pas pour moi la pire vidéo c'est
peut-être celle d'hier parce qu'il faut
toujours chercher à l'améliorer moi je
sais pas
mais fois je sais pas
je sais pas peut-être les premières
parce que tu être ma toute première
vidéo parce qu'il ya aucun contenu en
fait si tu regardes en réalité il ya
aucun contenu parce que je sais pas je
sais pas faire vidéo alors je dis pas
qu'aujourd'hui je suis voilà tu vois on
se raconte pas mais mes jeux s'est fait
un peu mieux aimer mais par rapport à ce
que je savais faire demain aujourd'hui
je ne suis pas encore bon donc il ya
beaucoup de travail
à propos de la sortie de l'iphone 14 pro
tu vas loin est-ce que tu as une info il
est beaucoup trop tôt abdel prendre des
infos sur l'iphone 14 pro on aura des
infos les premiers lits que dans
quelques mois pour l'instant c'est
encore un peu tôt on parle de
potentiellement de plus de portes charge
que d'avoir que la recharge sans fil bon
là je ne sais pas je sais pas du tout
vis-à-vis de l'expérience que tu as des
smartphones as-tu déjà utilisé une
alternative à android et que penses tu
de ces dérives que penses tu de ces
dérives ok
une alternative à android
alors est un os est une alternative à
android
on peut se parler également de ski à
chier huawei même si aujourd'hui on
n'est pas encore vraiment sur harmony os
mais ça va arriver
cela montre qu'ils vivent
je vois pas en fait ou aller sur la
question des dérives si tu veux moi je
pense que ce qui est important de
l'expérience
lié à android et aux alternatives
d'android donc aujourd'hui tu as un os
et tu as harmonie ouest mais bon faut
encore un peu de développement dessus
pour que ce soit pour l'instant on est
encore sur emi ou encore sur une base
d'android donc bon ça va arriver
je pense que
l'alternative elle est intéressante
parce que c'est toujours
bien de voir comment est-ce que d'autres
marques vont réussir à se projeter sur
l'usd utilisation comment l'utilisateur
va venir prendre en main l'expérience
différemment
de ses dérivés pardon excusez moi j'ai
mal lu ta question que penses tu de ses
dérivés
je trouve que
ces dérives et il y en a 2 aujourd'hui
eyeos je suis plutôt
[Musique]
excusez moi je reçois un message du type
studio en même temps il dit que le flux
actuel est trop est supérieur au débit
est recommandé 10 de calmer le cas de la
cadence me suivre tu vas tu envoies ton
votre dû
ouais j'en sais rien je sais pas je ne
veux pas te dire de de conneries
non mettre un peu dans le flux parce que
vous me racontez j'adore les vidéos
c'est intuitif intéressant merci
beaucoup
est ce que tu es un perfectionniste dans
tes vidéos ou est ce que tu te prends
pas la tête alors je ne suis pas un
perfectionniste dans mes vidéos je suis
quelqu'un d'efficace c'est vraiment ce
que je veux faire c'est l'efficacité
je veux pas bâcler je suis pas là pour
bâcler messieurs là pour être efficace
le le juste tant sur le juste contenu
c'est pour moi ce qui est important
salut tout le monde salue monsieur greu
dans quel logiciel de montage principal
sur wii n'est à ios le chef de montage
principal est alors moi je monte sur
final cut pro mais sur windows la
première qui est une top
du conte c'est quoi comme téléphone de
moins de 6 pouces un iphone
possible de faire plus de live avec un
seul thème on pourra se faire sa ba ouai
mais surtout oui je peux je pense tu
vois on réfléchira est ce que tu penses
seb que tu poses la question que un live
doit avoir un seul thème alors on a des
live avec un seul thème lors d'une
keynote par exemple qu'un lancement des
nausées fold en sont les nouveaux
samsung lance monde si ça on a un thème
mais est-ce qu'on doit se limiter
diabaté aujourd'hui on parle que de ça
je sais pas moi je suis tellement calton
crunch témoin il paraît plein de trucs
dites moi ce que vous en pensez
d'ailleurs
je vois pas des galaxies bud savoir bien
comment on participe donc on l'a pas
lancer encore dit 'de haut vol' faire je
vais je trouver un truc à faire on va
voir on va voir
tu as une idée taf avec de
l'informatique tels que tu présentes
soit à une idée de taf avec de
l'informatique tels que tu présentes sur
la chaîne en fait tu vois nil je pense
que si tu veux
si tu me parles de tel que je le
présente ça veut donc dire présenter ça
veut dire rendre service dont dire
expliqué eh ben tu as dans
l'informatique il faut que tu sois
conseil informatique tu peux bosser chez
des ldlc tu vois des boutiques
spécialisées comme ça qu'ils vont tu vas
voir une relation client ou tu va
présenter expliquer ça c'est intéressant
ça te force à connaître des produits si
tu veux bien faire ton métier à les
connaître à les expliquer à savoir
conseiller et à écouter le client ça
c'est intéressant faire
je vais avoir le m20 f 5 g à noël
j'espère que tout d'actualité ouais très
cool teddy tu t'inquiètes est ce que tu
es ce que tu pourras présenter le au pot
à 16 je ne pense pas je crois qu'il y
avait eu un smartphone au mas de linux
je ne sais pas
tu peux excuser moi je commence à
fatiguer mais je suis très heureux
d'être avec vous c'est il faut que je
vois plutôt tu en penses quoi des shorts
sur youtube je pense que c'est un sujet
très intéressant à développer les shorts
mais il faut trouver une ligne qui soit
complémentaire avec la chaîne pas faire
la même chose tel que ce captain petit
short je pense que je vois plein de
petits shorts je vais voir des trucs tu
vois par exemple à las vegas je veux
aller au cs et un truc qui ne citera pas
forcément une vidéo je pense que je vais
faire en sorte d'en match à regarder ce
que j'ai trouvé ça c'est marrant on peut
faire si voilà ça ça ça et sur le vif et
paf poster poste et poster ça fait plein
de petits contenu à venir voir qu'ils
sont vachement intéressant mais que je
pourrai pas vous développez en dix
minutes sur youtube
[Musique]
quels sont les smartphones qui
concurrencent bien apple et samsung en a
plein regarde leurs chiens ont mis sur
le haut de gamme c'est pas encore là où
on lui a tout de suite mais ils sont
mais je pense à des eaux peau très
claire mon super marque peau fine x3 pro
top comme smartphone tu as plein de très
jolis mcveigh vaut aussi qui continue à
monter en gamme tourne très joli produit
très très cool quoi
pourquoi ne pas faire un savoir discorde
à ça c'est dans les tuyaux j'avais pu
lire on a souvent parlé sur twitter bah
tiens regarde tu sais quoi je me to do
list mais je vais me le marquer tout de
suite j'ai pas marqué je me marre et
tout de suite je marquais serveurs
discorde je vais regarder et
parce que
je n'ai pas fait un plat je veux mais là
tout doux
j'ai marqué faire discorde
comme ça ça fait partie de ma liste de
tout doux à faire pour pour les fêtes
tac oh là là on va arriver en 2020 ne te
dirai que tellement de projets je vois
qu'on pourra pas y arriver
c'est bien plusieurs thèmes ok merci
arthur ont rebondi sur la question tout
à l'heure l'idée de faire un live avec
intel ok
[Musique]
tu penses quoi de maillezais impro
intéressant mais ça commence à vieillir
as tu un lien une chaîne tweet faut
participer au prochain live depuis le
début prochain live
arthur oui dans la description de cette
vidéo là tu as j'aime me battre ils sont
mon caméra qui fait la tronche tu es
fort que ça change sinon on va être
bloquée dans quelques instants on va
aller rester comme ça on verra oui oui
tu as un lien tout de suite là en
dessous de mon de machines twitch tu
veux dire d'abonnés
peux-tu me faire une dédicace il te
plait salua clader salut à toi pour tout
iphone 14 sera pliant je te confirme
qu'il ne sera pas bon je dois te laisser
penser à garder mes messages ça marche à
bientôt tels que je fais des bisous
j'adore tes vidéos synthe 8 iftar sans
merci a toi
d adana d'intenses parce que j'ai déjà
vu tout ça ou pas allez on va se reculer
je tendais créer un jeu temps créer un
discorde non en fait merci pour ta
proposition mais je le ferai parce que
il faut vraiment que je vois comment ça
marche que je comprenne et ensuite je le
ferai et puis peut-être qu'on se rend et
live où je demanderai des astuces des
conseils pour des scores et on pourra
regretter à ce moment l'ensemble mais
pour l'instant il faut vraiment me
laisser regarder et que je me mette
dedans que je comprenne comment ça
marche allez on se pèle conte le petit
concours dans dans trois minutes mieux
vaut les deux shorts tee shirts ou les
in stores in-stat pour moi c'est la même
chose c'est une question plateforme
c'est la concurrence
les shorts en fait ça vient concurrencer
les
comment on appelle ça ça n'est
concurrence et tik tok les risques d'un
stage à la concurrence et tik tok qui
viennent tous se concurrencer les uns
les autres dis donc vous êtes nombreux à
venir d'un coup là je parle de tweets
vous arrive et je vois qu'il ya plein de
personnes qui viennent de s'abonner sur
twitter merci à vous souvenir parce que
pour les live on va être nombreux et on
fera plein de la vie par rigoles ou quoi
ça va être super cool mais vous êtes
vous êtes combien à débarquer sur
twitter cool ça me fait marrer on fait
un live youtube et vous arrivez sur
twitter c'est tellement drôle fait de
voir attendez je m sont moins mon truc
de twitch et je regardais
up la fois les où je me suis dit des
fois à la ramasse complet dans ces trucs
dit donc mais vous êtes super nombreux
est devenu assez trop cool ça me fait
plaisir merci
mais oui trop génial génial ce désamour
trop génial c'est d'un casting je vous
fais un i live sur youtube et vous venez
tout sur twitter c'est tellement drôle
et de faire la gueule il était petit
voisin
saluer monsieur ries qui habitent à
moins que ton casque gelé d'élite à
l'heure c'est un bailleur dynamique pour
toi quels sont les futures technologies
pendant les smartphones dans les années
à venir moi ça va toujours des âmes et
des améliorations de capteurs ça va être
des capteurs des optiques plus fine ça
va être des gravures plus petites qui
sont toujours plus économes en énergie
ça va être plus de performances avec des
meilleurs écrans enfin voilà pour moi ce
qui va être intéressant c'est une fois
de plus le pia bucella roulable selway
riebel comment est ce qu'on arrive à
intégrer un smartphone dans autre chose
que ça parce que pour moi ça voyez j'ai
pas celui là mais ce form factor là
c'est déjà un peu passé c'est déjà un
peu passer ça pour moi c'est passé voyez
un smartphone comme ça cette taille
comprends qu'on met dans une poche c'est
assez clairement donc maintenant c'est à
quoi va ressembler un smartphone qui
sera plus cool qu'ils pensent vraiment
une place alors on voit bien on peut les
plier on peut enrouler un peu brooke est
ok ok ok ses débuts l'histoire mais ça
c'est fini ce format là c'est fini c'est
trop petit donc on va arriver sur le
faire on verra mais je pense que je
pense que le lan roulable c'est celle à
venir
ou le pliable ou noir et blanc on verra
eux
[Musique]
sont avec nous mais surtout et surtout
les fins de live tweet jean mode asmr
lumière rouge ça c'est marx c'est drôle
c'est drôle c'est drôle que penses tu
des crypto nft métavers ce sont des
sujets très différents et
complexes et à la fois qu'ils se
complètent le metaverse on se parle
d'une évolution d'internet
où on se plonge dans un monde virtuel où
on va venir payer en crypto et où on va
acheter les oeuvres d'art des mft donc
c'est c'est des sujets qui sont à la
fois différent mais transverses donc
c'est c'est intéressant ça ça en tout
cas ça montre comment fonctionne comment
on peut fonctionner les codes cet
univers virtuel qui pour l'instant reste
un peu
donné je vais dire des années gens
avertis mais qui pourrait être
la norme peut-être plus tard faut voir
ça fait bizarre quand même de venir
parce que je vais aller acheter des nfc
via ok je suis propriétaire de cette
oeuvre d'art en numérique tout le monde
peut avoir une copie mais j'ai mon
certificat
d'originalité ça m'appartient je
continue à trouver c'est un peu un peu
zarbi mais je comprends
je comprends l'idée à voir
nous parle de tout cela on arrive mon
gars arriver arrive et on verra surtout
de bientôt merci aux voyages catteau que
j'ai choisi mon nouveau téléphone mais
coûte avec grand plaisir
[Musique]
qu'est ce que tu me proposes comme
tablette gaming j'ai déjà eu cette
petite à la haye cette garde là
pour moi c'est très bien pour tu
t'appelles greu avec fr tu as une autre
chaîne en anglais et ouais j'ai commencé
à créer une chaîne en anglais il ya
trois ans et puis je me suis rendu
compte que je n'arrivais pas en fait
trop de travail donc je sais c'est en
stand-by complet
est ce qu'il y aura un jour un téléphone
transparent comme tony stark pas sûr
j'ai pas sûr je vais pas sûr tu pense
qu'il y aura un téléphone tesla je pense
que ça fait partie en tout cas des des
projets de tesla 1 je vois pas commenter
cela pourrait se dire on va permettre de
téléphone ça me paraîtrait logique mais
voir comment il faut le faire je sais
pas les caméra invisible sous l'écran
pour bientôt tu penses basse est déjà là
en quelque sorte on l'a vu avec le z
folle de 3 2 de samsung à l'intérieur
je pense que oui oui ça fait partie des
choses qui vont arriver cette année
fortement
tu pourrais faire une vidéo sont les
prochains produits tels que ses
smartphones ils sortiront prochainement
dominante et un hélico annonce
officielle je sais pas si c'est géré
chercher peut-être je sais pas on va
réfléchir
ok allez vous êtes prêt on va se faire
gagner le nouveau au pot reynaud syspro
raynaud parce qu'il dit nouveau parce
qu'ils sortent il n'y a pas si longtemps
que ça mais on va se faire ça alors il
faut que je trouve une idée il faut que
je trouve une idée de deux concours un
peu un peu pas pas trop compliqué
attendait ces malades et on a déjà reçu
l'e-mail de david un donc david merci
pour ton email
hop là
c'est top
j'ai les captures d'écran c'est nickel
j'ai la complète david merci je sais pas
c'est encore là mais c'est bon j'ai reçu
alors on va réfléchir comment est-ce
qu'on peut le faire gagner alors
souvenez vous on va revenir peut-être
une petite heure en arrière on a fait
gagner le au port et no 6 ok maintenant
il y aura gagné l'eau pour elles aussi
seront souvenez vous pour faire gagner
le lot pour gagner c'est ce qu'on a fait
on a fait un truc très simple vous ai
demandé quels étaient donnés mois le
titre exact de ma première vidéo sur un
smartphone de europe au hockey bravo à
david qui a gagné c'était un peu
complexe parce qu'il fallait vraiment
montants arrière maintenant on va
essayer de trouver un truc un peu plus
cool un peu plus un alors comment on va
faire je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je
ne sais pas je suis en train de
réfléchir alors je vais réfléchir je
prends mon smartphone joie et sur
youtube et j'ai essayé de trouver un
truc cool ok alors attendez est ce que
vous y êtes
concentrez-vous 1 ouvrez grand vos
oreilles parce que il ya un smartphone à
gagner et pas n'importe lequel on se
parle du au port et nos six pros qui un
smartphone cool et ça serait dommage de
ne pas être concentré à ce moment-là de
la vidéo je vais donc vous poser une
question la première personne qui me
répondra écoutez moi bien à ma réponse
et
qui je ne sais pas quoi
remportera le smartphone alors j'ai dit
je ne sais pas quoi parce que ces prêts
soient pas trouvé le le l'intitulé du
truc mais je vais trouver je vais
trouver
je suis en train de réfléchir
j'espère que vous êtes concentré parce
que quand ça va arriver à falloir claque
est prêt
est-ce que vous êtes prêts
ok
ah j'ai un truc un peu un peu un peu un
peu bullshit ne savait trop bullshit si
je vous fais ça c'est trop bullshit
j'allais vous demander quel est le
premier concours j'ai fait sur ma chaîne
mais c'est trop bullshit c'est vraiment
trop bullshit et une tondeuse à barbe
parce qu'on se reprenne tout à l'heure
donc je ferais pas ça je ne ferai pas ça
je vais réfléchir alors qu'est ce que je
peux vous proposer si j'ai une idée là
j'ai une idée mais ça va pas être simple
commencent à remonter l'historique
remonter l'historique
je vais essayer de vous trouver un truc
rigolo
sur ma chaîne youtube
vous êtes prêt concentrez vous ce que
vous êtes prêts
sur ma chaîne youtube vous l'avez vu
tout au début
je ne parlais pas que de teck
voile était de vue soyez concentré parce
qu'on parle quand même nos smartphones à
gagner le port et nos six pros je ne
parlais pas que tech ok
il faudra écrire la réponse dans le chat
un
ok je vais vous poser une question la
première personne qui me donnera la
bonne réponse dans le chatt
repartira avec rien entendre et les
pompiers n'ont repartira avec le au port
et nos six pros je vous le dis tout de
suite la personne je donnerai le nom du
gagnant je veux regarder le chat à la
première personne qui me donne la bonne
réponse repart avec son au port et no 6
po ok on est d'accord là dessus dites
vous bien que je donnerais nom de la
personne cette personne-là devra
m'envoyer très rapidement un email vous
avez mon adresse e-mail qui est dans la
section à propos de ma chaîne youtube
sinon ces lots @ monsieur gros point fr
vous devrez m'envoyer un email avec des
captures d'écran de votre compte youtube
pour je vois que c'est bien vous pour
être certifié que c'est bien vous et que
c'est bien votre bon pseudo et que voilà
quelqu'un tant de passe de pas se faire
passer pour vous il faudra m'envoyer
votre
nom prénom adresse postale numéro de
téléphone je ne les concernait pas mais
je les transmettrai à au pot pour
qu'elle puisse vous envoyez votre
smartphone ok alors on y va en se
concentrant va gagner attention
concentration au maximum sur ma chaîne
youtube tout au début écoutez moi bien
tout au début je ne parlais pas que tech
je vous ai parlé d'une hotte thématiques
je vous ai parlé cuisine je fais une
recette de cuisine sur ma chaîne il y a
une et une seule recette de cuisine sur
ma chaîne dites moi quel plat je vous ai
préparé et le premier qui me dit quelle
plage et préparer repart avec son au
port et nos six pros c'est parti je
regarde le chat
quel est le plat la recette que j'ai mis
sur ma chaîne youtube il ya une seule
recette de cuisine une seule a
on à gaël galles qu'il l'a dit
segal c'est le premier qui l'a miguel
lecoq carbonara exactement c'est des
pâtes à la carbonara
alors je te la corde secteur ont pu
mettre pâtes à la carbonara mais
carbonara on sait de quoi on parle ça
des pâtes et riz carbonara vous êtes ya
répondu à presser cavilleri qui a
répondu juste après il ya aussi mdh cas
bon ok alors veuve de cobain non c'était
pas ça c'est sur une autre chaîne
donc je note gaëlle qui va gagner gaël
le coq up
gueule tu m'envoies par par par email tu
m'envoies des captures d'écran que je
sois bien que c'est toi que ce soit bien
sûr que c'est toi pour que tu puisse
repartir bien évidemment avec ton au
port et nos six pro tu m'envoies ton nom
ton adresse ton numéro de téléphone pour
qu'on puisse envoyer le smartphone je ne
regarderai pas une faute plus tes
coordonnées mais que au popiste les
envoyer fait ça vite et comme ça c'est
cool ça peut partir d'elle parce qu'on
m'avait marqué quand même de ton poids
des pâtes ouais c'était pas assez
c'était pas assez explicite
[Musique]
patrick haouat en été vous avez de
musique au tac à wana pataca bonaparte
boeuf de kobé j'ai fait une chaîne qui
s'appelait au service des gens et par là
j'avais fait une chaîne avec un pote qui
s'appelle on s'invite et on teste enfin
on s'invite dans un resto restaurateurs
qui nous invitaient et honda tester le
boeuf de kobe et on avait scénarisé ça
et on faisait les on vous un peu les
cons et mon pote il s'est fait insulter
alors que parce qu'en fait on premier
pour un connard alors renversé juste de
l'humour quoi mais bon on a pour ne pas
être explicite de croix là dessus la
n'auriez pas eu tout de lasagnes gérald
à zain zain ruby gratin vidéo sport non
recettes de pâtes pas de cars bloqués
lasagnes spaghettis bolognaise pas du
tout carbonara italienne ou ipad avec
anne hathaway ok vous était bon voilà
c'est segal qui était le plus rapide
bravo à elle on se refera d'autres on se
refera d'autres
j'ai donné le titre exact exact c'est
vrai mais c'était je demandais pas le
titre exact je demandais en fait le plat
le plat le plat bon et vous savez quoi
on se refera d'autres concours on se
l'est fera je pense sur twitter on sera
à gagner 10 trucs on se fera des trucs
comme ça de rapidité c'est marrant on va
là vous inquiétez pas
je te parle puis métro forme par les
jeux par cinq secondes le château plus
actif depuis le début il ya
les vois la gueule tu as gagné
félicitations c'est moi qui écris
premier pâtes à la carbonara
ah non j'ai pas d'accord c'était bien
c'était bien galles qui l'écrit en
premier je garde montée le chat 1 ça ne
dérange pas mais
pour moi c'est
jean contre le tchad attend pâtes à la
carbonara gaël qui a marqué carbonare tu
vois moment où j'ai donné le truc
on dit on à rugby nourriture reste au
violon la guitare la tondeuse dont tu
vois j'ai donc c'était vraiment c'est
vraiment qu'elle sait vraiment quel donc
voilà
bonne soirée bonne nuit monsieur grue
aux abonnés merci pour tes conseils
salut fred
un autre concours on se fera donc en
toute une journée pas d'entrain
j'en ai pas d'autre tout de suite j'ai
deux smartphones a offert gagner donc
c'est déjà bien quand même c'est déjà
pas mal pour une soirée on se fera
d'autres concours comme ça et puis c'est
sympa moi j'aime bien je trouve ça
j'aime bien j'aime bien cette ambiance
où on réfléchit c'était trouve un peu
décidé on fera mieux ça je pense qu'on
fera un truc sur tout mais je veux
mettre en place je vous appellerai
directement je ferai peut-être un petit
séchées ou mika effet sachez que c'est
un match intéressant quand ils font leur
live sur twitter un petit google docs ou
vous mettez vous vos coordonnées et puis
il vous appelle et après ils font un
petit qui veut gagner des millions au
téléphone il ya peut-être un truc à
faire un truc un peu rigolo voilà ça
peut permettre à ce que tout le monde
joue dans les meilleures conditions lors
il faut aussi en live avec frandroid où
les personnes peuvent jouer directement
via une appli peut-être un truc à faire
je sais pas fait peut-être un truc à
réfléchir mais on fera des trucs
marrants tout cas un peu moins à larache
que là je vous le cache pas coucou de la
guadeloupe salut à joss j'adore la
guadeloupe j'y suis allé à quelques
années c'est dans un spot ouf issime
et
soyez padeg mais ne soyez pas dès qu'on
en fera date des concours on en fera
plein les poches on s'organisera on
s'organisera en faire des trucs ensemble
je donne un peu le chat bah oui je
comprends
maxime demande xamax où je patinais
as-tu des enfants j'ai un petit garçon
d'un petit elliott
petit message
du coup dans quelle vidéo avoue t il pas
sur ma chaîne ans et donne de toute
première vidéo le titre c
mais je crois va de sa recette des pâtes
à la carbonara italienne
7997 vu j'ai 79 % de j'aime je crois que
les gens pas trop aimé pourtant elle est
très bonne entre 7 et je continue à la
faire aujourd'hui je la mange toujours
un grand plaisir voyez
tu peux faire gagner un trombone bien
sûr on va y penser nord la prochaine
fois je serai gagnant trop vote
peut-être n'est pas aujourd'hui
il ya toujours rien à gagner pour celui
qui a trouvé ton agent promet toujours
pas mais bien essayer en tout cas mes
tantes et s'étonne un milliard tout de
suite maintenant tu ferais quoi si je te
donnais un milliard tout de suite c'est
le milliard c'est ce qu'on appelle un
lait c'est ça notre nom pour les gâteaux
à la caf ou de la cerise je mangerai
grand plaisir
beaucoup la france salut à toi badtech
il vous côtoyez français qui nous
regardent
continue comme ça merci beaucoup pour
les petits messages d'amour un avis pour
la pénurie des gpu qu'on traverse ouais
il ya hier il n'y a pas que gpu qui
impacte et il ya toute la tête qui
impacte est donc bon c'est pas simple on
va attendre de voir
si ça arrive un petit peu à se résoudre
cette année et zemmour on en parle ou
pas on n'en parle pas que penses tu du
chiot mimi 11 light 5 j'ai
pas mal pas mal pas mal
ait pour les new technology en 2022 on
va voir on va voir en 2022 ce qui se
profile je vais déjà fait une vidéo gta
way pour vous montrer un peu le leur au
portrait robot du smartphone de l'année
prochaine
et on voit déjà un peu ce qui va arriver
en termes de paix afghan terme de photos
après on va voir comment les
constructeurs mettent tous en place mais
c'est intéressant
pourrais-tu au jour faire une rencontre
abonnés à clermont écoute je pense qu'on
fera des rencontres abonnés quand cette
histoire de comics sera un peu derrière
nous on arrivera à se revoir facilement
fera des trucs ensemble ouais avec grand
plaisir on ira on ira faire ça on ira
chez mon pote mick et aux meilleures
lignes à clermont tu fais du sport sur
clermont n'ont pas trop il faudrait je
devrais me porte il faudrait tu peux me
faire gagner un trombone bientôt bientôt
on fera un live spécial trombone mais en
le temps que le plus useless du monde
allait à gagner des trombones et un clou
à prévenir un clou je ne sais pas et
vous fait ça et c'est grâce à ton fait
que j'assume pseudo exactement
[Musique]
au petit message je pense que aller
d'ici dix grosses minutes on va laisser
faire un gros bisou et on va aller se
coucher parce qu'enfin mais en tout cas
parce que je veux garder l'énergie pour
demain
j - avant le réveillon de noël qu'est ce
que vous faites pour noël des redites
l'émoi
et la hype de la marque nothing au nord
par and nothing l'année prochaine je
pense que rien du tout intéressant à
voir
je vais cuisinier sérieux je vais
cuisiner des pâtes avec abonnés entre
classes dites moi ce que vous faites
pour les fêtes ainsi on parlait un peu
de vous de vos vacances c'est quoi votre
votre fils plutôt à faire gagner c'est
quoi votre programme pour les fêtes est
ce que vous vous partez vous voyez de la
famille vous profiter un peu alors je
sais que la situation est un peu
complexe mais bon huawei est il mort ou
pas n'ont pas du tout pas du tout mort
rend compte à bonnac l'amour on
regardera ça
[Musique]
moi aussi il faudrait que je prenne une
licence de tennis sur clermont on voit
bien prochain potes qui jouent aux biens
monsieur drevet vidéo
[Musique]
mon groupe et ben merci trop cool en
famille à noël liesse je mange beaucoup
pour noël éric noël c'est pas la période
la plus meilleure pour le régime bonjour
monsieur groupe peux tu me conseillait
jeudi d' acheter un chiot me pas de 5 où
on me dit vous propose mes études c'est
pas la même chose
c'est pas la même chose si tu veux pour
les études telles qu'il faut un
ordinateur peut-être que le magic book
pro ira mieux tu vois ou regardent même
le magic book 14s s'il peut convenir une
zone question prière mais regarde ça si
c'est pas indiscret pourquoi votre fils
n'est plus dans vos vidéos je trouve ça
sympathique j'ai jamais mis dans mes
vidéos des foyers savoie des fois ils
passaient par là mais
parce que quand je fais mes vidéos en
deux le général il est pavé rebond en ce
moment je les fais beaucoup à paris
tu parle pas beaucoup de pc fixes non
ben c'est pas trop mon truc des infos
pour le cs bonnes fêtes de fin d'année
j'ai déjà des infos mais je peux pas en
parler tout de suite on verra folle de 3
je te conseille le find haine qui est je
regarde un peu petit message il faut
faire un tweeter space aurélien comme ça
on va vous parler on pourrait peut-être
faire ça mais en fait il ya tellement et
ses problèmes il ya une démultiplication
des plateformes donc ça veut dire que si
on veut se faire un truc sur twitter on
veut se faire un live sur twitter un
tweeter sur tik tok partout ça demande
une organisation presque tous les jours
un live par plateforme c'est un peu
complexe mais on va voir on va réfléchir
on va réfléchir pour noël je vais prier
pour gagner un smartphone un mobile de
free gagne en tout cas suis là je fête
pas noël ok ma famille al claque au vide
du coup noël en tête-à-tête avec mon
sapin cette année fuck je sais pas qui
aura de bons programmes sur netflix ou à
la télé
nintendo switch pas mal penses-tu faire
une vidéo test sur le vivo v21 je ne
pense pas meilleure parade vivo l'année
prochaine one + 9 pro grâce à toi trop
cool direction l'italie une semaine
après le nouvel an ça ça va être
chouette hein vincent quel est ton
programme
type d'une journée en bas comme tout le
monde je me lève
j'emmène reçoit clermont jamais mon fils
à l'école et puis je fais mon boulot ici
et puis je vais chercher à l'école et
puis on fait les devoirs ou alors je
suis à paris je me lève je me lève
toujours en fait ces principes et puis
je tourne je bosse je vais à des
rendez-vous
voilà mais comme dans ce moment je n'ai
plus cessé de gagner du temps
[Musique]
beaucoup de personnes vont se revoir
c'est intéressant ça vous ça vous
interroge pour
noël et les deux prochains mois je suis
à vancouver oh mais normalement j'habite
au québec continue sur cette lancée
monsieur je remercie beaucoup
félix-antoine c'est quoi cette caméra
stepc un sony à 7 et 3 savez monsieur
gros salut à toi
bonjour de la papouasie où c'est loin ça
coucou papouasie tu le disque est ce
enfin actuellement c'est un iphone 13
promax
un live sur omegle sinon pour les
abonnés va savoir peut-être un jour
[Musique]
mon comité sont contents
que penses tu de la paix watch est ce
nike bassine appalaches et ceux jamais
avait pas match et ce que j'aime bien je
trouve intéressante pour les vacances je
vais visiter mon salon puis ma cuisine
puis mon bureau puis ma chambre puis re
ma cuisine puis ma chambre eh ben c'est
un bon programme ça n'est pas encore
maintenant tu as à chaque fois ben moi
je suis content que mon ex 9
tu penses quoi des biscuits dinos russe
d'avis là dessus
la la la la la on aimerait bien
devoir faire un peu de tout pc portables
gaming pas juste les tels que pensez
vous
ouais mais moi je pense que c'est
compliqué d'être partout en même temps
il faut faire attention ruben audigy les
bonnes soirées salut ruben à bientôt
coucou de saturne c'est encore plus loin
ouais c'est loin saturnin sur les
anneaux tu vas surface va être cool
votre avis sur le retour de tom shayes
10 en 2014 car fait saïdi que le coc
vider les masques sait pas où on faith
heidi ça marche bien avec le masque
était masqué qu'une apple watch donc
pour moi ça va faire vendre des appels
web chez apple donc je pense pas que
child urbaine en force
merci pour tes vidéos merci à toi
tu me conseilles quel iphone pour 2022
bah envers en 2022 j'ai envie de te dire
je pense c'était quand même mon premier
message sur un chat youtube c'est pas
avoir égales eh ben dis donc
ça s'appelle avoir la chance
ça s'appelle avoir de la chance
a battu m'a répondu pâtes carbonara
ok
je regarde en même temps
ça marche
trop cool et ben j'en vois ça demain à
au pot que ce soit pour david bourghelle
comme ça vous aurez vau l'eau bah je
pense que tout le monde sera vendu de
vacances au revoir monsieur vraie bonne
soirée allez on va se prendre on va
jusqu'à 23h30 il nous reste neuf minutes
à passer ensemble après je j'irai me
coucher parce qu'il ya un moment il faut
se reposer et en tout cas je tiens à
vous remercier parce que c'était un vrai
plaisir d'être avec vous ce soir on va
se garder encore un petit moment ça fait
vingt-cinq et 2h24 qu'on est ensemble
jeu très heureux voyez vivement le
million tu ne mérites pas j'aimerais
beaucoup on verra si on y arrive un jour
on verra ce qui se passe on sait pas on
sait pas ce qui va se passer ou pas on
verra je regarde un petit peu allez on
va se faire un petit tour des messages
l'a vivement 2 millions d'abonnés
aimez-vous le pot findings de light en
dominant il a un peu vieilli l'eau pour
fanny l'institut sympa mais c'est pas ce
que je recommanderais aujourd'hui tu ne
fais pas de duo avec un youtuber
spécialement le pc on pourrait faire des
trucs ya plein de choses à faire une
chaîne de gaming m recommandé je suis
pas gamer donc je ne saurais pas trop te
te recommander je vois pas trop de
chaînes de gaming
il ya beaucoup de questions sur ouais
ouais parce que ils sont en train de
faire quelque chose sur harmony os en
chine est sortie des voitures harmonie
os au sortir des chaufferies beauté
lyrique non mais c'est un très gros
écosystèmes huawei c'est une boîte qui
est énorme aujourd'hui en france qu on
envoie
faut se dire qu'en ce qui se passe en
chine c'est beaucoup plus lourd donc ils
ont bon sous le pied mais ils ont
l'innovation donc on va voir ce qui
arrive en
renminbis pro trop d'actualité c'est
toujours une question de budget donc si
ça rentre dans le budget que why not
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas
il ya un sdf sur cdiscount à 439 euros
ça vaut le coup e
ça me paraît pas des conneries ça me
paraît pas déconner
tu vas y arriver tes vidéos les tests
elle donc très bien fait merci photos
dédicacées
personne qui ait choisi l'année
connais-tu jaugeas oui bien sûr bien sûr
on se connaît tous dans la tête qu'on
est tous
j'aime bien johan c'est un mec très
sympa
tu as l'air cuit je suis un peu fatigué
là mais je suis heureux d'être avec vous
un grand plaisir un grand merci pour ce
live
ça fait vraiment plaisir passe ce cap
chat tu sais encore billon ce truc je
suis pas sur ce match à 12 et 60 ch a
d'ailleurs dit les mois
va me les repasse de bonnes fêtes avec
ta femme et ton fils au buzzer secret
circle amont la bise avec grand plaisir
et merci pour ton message monsieur greu
tu pourrais faire prochainement quelle
tv à moins de 500 ou à moins de 3000 ou
à la télé à 200 euros se plaît je t'en
prie on vers pourquoi pas ton avis sur
le haut pour 74 bien intéressant homme
intéressant intéressant
et puis la corrida
direct est question c'est un sujet
compliqué les cordages pouvoir découvrir
et ton petit parce que ma mère aimait la
corrida non je connais la corrida il ya
un vrai problème de de non choix de
l'animal dont mais je comprends que
pauleta des traditions mais je pense
qu'à mon sens et c'est un sujet complexe
se retrouver là parce que on va quand
même faire un maître un animal dans une
arène qui ne maîtrise pas nécessairement
les règles et qui à la fin à
80g pas 19% j'ai parlé c'est exact meurt
alors on dit que c'est un combat pour
moi c'est juste de le sait surtout de la
réaction de l'animal qui est boosté à
testostéroné et qui voilà donc bon c'est
compliqué
arnaud c'est pour les ordis à exactement
on est d'accord là dessus et tu vois
merci pour cette bonne fête à tous nous
disons merci à toi pp sympa aussi bébé
est une crème je te confirme qu'elle est
on youtube hairtech préférées je n'ai
pas eu plein de bons potes qui font du
très bon travail ou les font tous
différemment donc
je veux pas de youtube ortec préférées
moi je regarde beaucoup aussi les
chaînes américaines beaucoup ce qui se
passe là bas et voilà
monsieur greu la samsung tab s6 light
est elle une bonne tablette
je vais m'endormir s'cusez moi j'suis
fatigué oui c'est sur une question de
prix regarde là cette light je me rends
pas compte à quel prix tu peut la
trouver mais s'il prix intéressant et
qu'elle correspond à des besoins des
usagers ce que donc tu as besoin en
terme de performance pourquoi pas
aucune question sur alcatel ouais c'est
vrai il vous auriez pu imposer quand
même il faut aussi en cinq ans d'être
avec toi merci je rêve de gagner un truc
en c4 t'inquiète pas ça il va ça finit
toujours par arriver la chance tourne
toujours
[Musique]
comment faire si on oublie nos
informations du compte nintendo et bon
courage et envie de te dire bonne nuit
abonnez vous allumez la cloche chez sade
exactement tu as compris un truc salue
monsieur gros j'adore tes vidéos comme
ça merci beaucoup c'est très gentil
merci pour ça elle a bientôt sur
clermont si jamais on se croise avec
grand plaisir pas hésité à me faire un
petit bisou enfin j'aime dire bonjour
d'avoir ce que c'est avec un bisou qu'on
se connaît pas ça va me faire bizarre
kiptoo monnaie tu investis je n'ai pas
de cryptome année je n'ai pris aucune
tu peux me présenter le s12 ultra quand
sortiront le ferai avec grand plaisir
je vous laisse aux cas bientôt quietus
stevens a déjà croisé de trois fois
préfère ton iphone ou un android pour
quotidien au quotidien son iphone que
j'utilise monsieur gros merci pour la
réponse avec grand plaisir
ok ils étaient encore nombreux et
nombreuses îles dont 15 est chaud patate
un an 40 ans j'ai encore rien gagné ça
finira par arriver garde un peu patience
la chance tourne toujours bon c'est
toujours au loto un peu plus dur mais on
sait jamais
c'est jamais stop spam je vois ça ok que
penses tu de la batterie de galaxy tab
est ce cette gelée depuis une semaine
est un peu déçu je trouve qu'à se
déchargent vite
castien à peine une journée sont
utilisés à fond combien attendre une
journée sans utiliser à fond combien de
temps tu l'utilisent
chaque thé réglages sur ta je sais plus
si on a tout infléchissement de cent
vingt ans on se souvient plus sur cette
tablette la regardant éventuellement si
tu peux pas optimisée des choses de ce
côté là pour garder est-ce que tu as
d'autres passions côté de la tech et la
musique
je veux bien faire la moto
sony xperia sont-ils de bons portable et
sont pas mal
akon une vidéo analyse comme une cabine
jeudi où les odeurs tu sais pas on verra
ce qu'on fera des choses aussi comme ça
bien
vegan power monsieur greu comment on
fait pour personnaliser un smartphone
rim me carle et mstor n'existe pas sur
l'airé demi en france regarde si tu peux
pas dire que tu es en inde et ensuite
devenir personnalisés des fois y'a des
trucs comme ça qui passe on ne sait pas
comment ça des fois
plus à partager la bise à clermont où
j'ai passé un an d'étude et lisima y est
c'est aussi tu peux me résumer la 5g stp
voilà avant il y avait la 4g il matière
à ce que j'ai fait résument-ils plus
contre projet de faire comment faire si
on oublie d'informations personnelles
sur des comptes nintendo je n'ai pas de
réponse à cette question tu es tout seul
derrière ta chaîne youtube tout seul
absolument tout seul sauf pour le
montage
soit à sa table 700 maires cessé de
descendre un petit peu au mieux on
adaptatif
la chaîne de jérémy du fournil une
amérique book ou un intérêt certain il
ya plein de très belles shehatta tous
les niveaux
[Musique]
j'adore les motards
l'uci fait de la moto aussi
comment séduire en trottinette ça c'est
un super sujet romain on pourrait
travailler sur ce sujet c'est
intéressant parce que tu viendras disons
ce n'est pas prévu j'ai pas de jets pas
de personnes que je vois qu'ils sont à
dijon donc je peux pas te dire
il y aura-t-il un test sur des cases de
réalité virtuelle à l'avenir on y
arrivera à l'avenir on y arrivera je ne
peux pas de dire quand mais on y
arrivera dès lors qu'il y aura un sujet
haute que la question du gaming je pense
à mon avis
le lien de la chaîne de mon pote arnaud
alors attends j'ai trouvé ça tout de
suite
youtube arnaud puis si vous voulez
passer si on peut l'aider à passer les
les 5000 abonnés il est à 4000
regarder jouer un lien
si on peut filer un coup de main à
arnaud parce qu'il le mérite
c'est m'a regardé
il le mérite
allez hop je vous mets le lien de sa
chaîne allez vous abonner tous
merci pour tes vidéos mais je remercie à
toi je revendicatif un moteur de 150
aspect bravo
je passe noël avec ma copine depuis
trois ans et demi qu'on est ensemble on
a un enfant de deux ans et demi hier
c'est beau ça j'aime
j'aime j'aime j'aime j'aime quelle moto
post tu j'ai une ducati monster c'est
une
[ __ ] j'ai bouffé non avec m c'est une
600 combien 695 lé 2007 un peu vieille
mais elle est cool
pour les chéris je vais vous dire au
revoir allez faire un petit cours sur la
chaîne de motards ne vous a mis le lien
là
on se revoit bien évidemment sur youtube
extrêmement rapidement on aura plein de
choses à se raconter il va encore y
avoir je vous dis la vidéo sur le nova
neuf qui va sortir bientôt après on
repartira début 2022 si tout se passe
bien je touche du bois j'ai du bois
touche du bois je touche ma tête est
encore du bois mais qui trouve le poteau
quai on se retrouvera à vegas avec plein
de choses plein d'innovations je
présenterai des choses bien évidemment
dans les shorts sur youtube je
présenterai sur des vidéos on regardera
plein de trucs on va essayer de faire
plein de nouveaux concepts on va essayer
de se réinventer en permanence faire
plein de nouvelles choses on se
retrouvera bien évidemment également
également également sur
/ / twitch sur les live sur tictoc
également donc si vous êtes sûr tik tok
sur instagram sur twitch venez me
rejoindre et puis le podcast fréquence
grue qui va repartir de plus belle j'ai
acheter du matos qui quelque part par là
bas pour pouvoir
l'emmener quand je partirai aux us pour
faire du podcast directement depuis et
vega donc ça sera cool on se retrouvera
à ce moment là je vous remercie ça m'a
fait très plaisir de pouvoir partager
partager ce ces deux heures ces deux
gros oeuvre ensemble encore
félicitations à david et à gehl qui ont
gagné c'est au port et no 6 et au port
et nos six pros on se retrouve nous très
vite on continuera par les tec merci
pour vos messages merci pour vos
encouragements merci pour vos messages
doux merci pour vos questions et pour
tous ces messages sympa que vous m'en
voyez donc je vous envoie aussi beaucoup
d'amour je vous souhaite d'excellentes
fêtes de fin d'année prenez du temps
pour vous pour votre famille pour vos
amis pour ceux que vous aimez et puis
voilà je vous souhaite le meilleur
que du bonheur que de la joie et puis
prenez soin de vous gros bisous à métro
[Musique]
tout l'enjeu
baj
[Musique]